[Musique]
bonjour Stéphane comment ça va
[Rires]
tu as supporté Kevin hier comment tu as
fait
vous aviez pas mis le son
Kevin bonjour à tous non la gueule j'ai
mis le son oui mais il y a le décalage
il y a un décalage d'une minute bonjour
à tous salut
et c'est vraiment dommage que quand il y
ait pas de son au début parce que
franchement ça a balancé hier sur Kevin
normal donc on m'a demandé comment j'ai
fait hier pour pour tenir tout le stream
aujourd'hui pour survivre à cet épisode
d'hier avec un stream contre enfin avec
contre la psy ça peut être contre une
partie à la partie ouh là ouf c'est des
blancs
c'est pas
elle est noire
que je vous ouais donc ce qui s'est
passé hier est-ce que il va changer et
moi je vais vous dire ce qui s'est passé
bon j'ai vu les tweets de Maxime la
première partie Maxime va chez agraveur
il est blanc Vladimir cramé qui se
chauffe depuis qu'il est retraité la
retraite Vladimir c'est il est né en
1975 donc la retraite à 48 ans pour
Vladimir il payait près pour aller
manifester en bas de ma rue là donc et
ben il avec cette avec cette sicilienne
il s'amuse ce jeune retraité et donc
victoire de Maxime qui dans les
complications a eu Vladimir donc
deuxième partie raconte nous
tous c'était moi j'ai vu ce qui s'est
passé la deuxième partie mais je crois
qu'il y a eu des petites déconnexion du
côté de Maxime déjà alors déjà ça je ne
savais pas parce que écoute ça avec
possible c'est pas possible mais en fait
nous on le voyait pas ouais en fait il
était que c'est ce qu'il a dit c'est
qu'il était connecté au zoom et qui
était déconnecté
de temps en temps du serveur chez
Swisscom bon ben ça arrive quand il y a
beaucoup de
qui a beaucoup de personnes voilà ça
arrive des petites c'est la magie et les
problèmes de l'informatique parfois on
s'est pas pourquoi il y a un souci donc
voilà bon donc il y a eu ça il y a eu ce
fameux sleep de Vladimir cramique
dame G5 avec la dame qui a été perdue en
chemin la souris qui voulait pas
s'arrêter là et voilà position était
compliquée rien rien était clair rien
n'est encore décidé et donc abandon bien
sûr de crameric donc 2-0 pour Maxime il
reste deux parties il faut qu'il fasse
un match nul pour se qualifier maxime a
décidé vraiment en gentleman de
d'abandonner la troisième partie pour
laisser le point à Kramnik parce qu'il
considérait que le point qu'il avait
gagné par le mausleep était pas mérité
donc donc l'abandonne donc il y a il y a
2-1 ce qui est marrant c'est que Maxime
a abandonné avec les blancs en plus donc
souvent là il s'est fait mater en cinq
coups voilà ils font ça avec son roi
pour se faire mater ouais donc
moi bah moi en fait tu veux quand j'ai
vu le mot slip
j'ai dit sur le stream j'ai dit je pense
Maxime va abandonnerait parce que je le
connais je sais qu'il est très fair-play
et qu'en plus il y a un grand respect
avec cramique et j'étais sûr qu'elle
allait lui rendre la partie tu es sûr et
ça n'a pas
ratévin devait penser que
rien à faire on encaisse le poids et
puis on joue à suivre non
en fait ça dépend du joueur parce que si
tu n'as qu'à moi qui m'explique je pense
qu'on a qu'à moi il va aller te faire
voir
il y aura pas de Boy
moi je le fais en tout cas moi c'est par
rapport à mon adversaire si je vois mon
adversaire ben c'est un peu un rat tu
vois je le ferai pas quoi si je vois que
c'est vraiment bon à cramé quoi là on
peut lui rendre
bien sûr avant de de reprendre un coup
ou de faire un truc comme ça je me
demande est-ce que la version de forêt
déjà c'est je le vois un peu comme ça
d'accord ok moi je en fait en vrai là je
m'occupais de Kevin mais je rends pas
moi
je rends pas et j'attends pas que je
veux pas du tout comment et voilà c'est
c'est la vie ça fait partie du jeu ça
fait partie et j'accepte c'est comme le
flag on en discutait l'autre jour
des circonstances moi je je considère
mais tu vois je prends pas du tout mal
et j'ai pas du tout envie qu'on me
rendre alors là ne me rendez pas si si
vous faites un petit fait à moi aussi
poussez pas quoi ne me rendez pas la
partie d'après j'aime pas ça donc je le
ferai pas mais j'attends pas du tout
comme le fasse donc
après chacun son maximum
chacun
fait comme il le sent mais j'ai eu un
feeling je pensais qu'il allait lui
rendre et il lui a rendu et ce qui est
marrant c'est que du coup un bel avait
les Noirs à la prochaine partie mais il
a sacrifié sa couleur pour la pour
rendre le pot et donc cramique a joué
ces trois premiers coups et ses quatre
au deuxième
et deux pour transposer dans une
Sicilienne c'est pas une Anglaise donc
je trouvais ça beau de la part des deux
joueurs qui s'entendaient et qui
comprenaient
ils sont pas prêts pour le chasboxing ah
oui non mais il a fait une partie
monstrueuse et franchement il a il a
créé des choses vraiment juste génial et
c'est déconnecté et puis il a une
position qui est nulle absolument quand
il veut ces deux cavaliers pions contre
Tours et plein de pions et il peut
parcours confiance quand il veut il y a
les cavaliers qui peuvent rien faire etc
avec de cavaliers où c'est qu'on m'a pas
hein sauf s'il reste des pions inversés
que des fois il peut y avoir des
pollutions il y a des il y a des pâtes
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué mais
normalement deux cavaliers contre roi
hein enfin c'est juste nul et donc il y
avait deux cavaliers et un pion pour
amnique donc pas de la tour elle a mangé
de pion à un moment donné et puis voilà
mais il y avait aucune chance de de
perdre pour Maxime sauf la déconnexion
et donc bah la télé connectée il a perdu
la partie et il a écrit un message dans
le dans le zoom je l'ai vu c'était un
truc du style
j'étais déconnecté mille fois je ne
jouerai pas la magasin
ouais et donc Vladimir cramique a
abandonné le match voilà donc moi on
pensait tous que ok ben cramique passe
au final en fait on va être que le slip
officiel chascom par des vachement à
mettre des résultats alors que tout le
résultat est variété était posté
c'est
compliqué mais en fait
du coup en fait paniquer il a rendu
parce qu'il a vu pas en fait
tu pourrais ne pas l'être mais après
maxime a fait je pense que non mais
c'est normal non mais là c'est vrai que
oui
en plus c'est pas la faute de Maxime
c'est le serveur c'est pas lui tu vois
bien sûr
ça arrive bon
voilà bon bah écoute faire play de la
part des deux joueurs qui se connaissait
bien je te l'avais dit Tu vois c'est
joueur qui ont travaillé ensemble là
donc ils se connaissent bien ils se
respectent et au final victoire méritée
de Maxime
la logique est quand même respectée et
donc il joue le jeune
ouzbek aujourd'hui
surprise l'année dernière
en 2021 donc fin 2021 tu es assez
impressionnant mais depuis ils fonce tel
confirme un peu comme tu l'avais dit un
peu un style moi je l'ai vu aux
Olympiades c'est marrant parce que c'est
encore une fois
une preuve de mon vieillissement mais
c'est c'est pour la première fois c'est
la première fois où tu je rencontre des
joueurs maintenant je vois des joueurs
pour la première fois et ils ont plus
d'élo que moi ce qui m'arrivait ce qui
ne m'est jamais arrivé en 20 ans tu vois
mais ce qui est maintenant ça m'arrive
en fait assez régulièrement
malheureusement ce qu'il y a un peu des
deux hein je baisse au vélo et en plus
les jeunes arrivent de plus en plus
jeunes donc en fait ça fait que je les
ai pas vu avant qu'ils aient plus de
vélo et donc je l'ai vu aux Olympiques
qu'ils ont gagné d'ailleurs où il était
le leader il était chéquier numéro 1 et
ouais un style un style déjà une une
attitude à la casse pas off c'est-à-dire
qu'il est motivé il arrive tu sens il
vient au buffet en étant le même hôtel
il vient au buffet il a pas de temps à
perdre il doit aller se préparer enfin
vraiment très il dégage quelque chose et
ça c'est assez étonnant tu vois cet
âge-là
il a déjà battu Magnus en partie en
partie lente et quand il a battu ma nu
bah je passe bien avant on les voyait on
voyait vraiment attitude devant
l'échiquier et il avait pas peur du tout
et il était là pour pour gagner quoi
ouais cette année
une grosse partie
et donc là Maxime ça lui fait pas peur
il est ils sont dans le braquer des
perdants mais ils sont en finale déjà
alors rappelons que le vainqueur de
cette finale ne gagne pas alors je me
suis trompé sur la division 2 bon ben
c'est bon on a compris Kevin
ouais je me suis trompé alors
mais effectivement mais ça serait
tellement plus logique franchement en
fait un truc je trouve mon système est
meilleur mais il se trouve que c'est pas
le système adopté mais bon il me
semblait donc
on me l'avait pas dit mais bon après bon
ah c'est facile
ok j'ai compris j'ai compris ok j'ai
compris l'ambiance
c'est c'est noté tu étais d'accord mais
bon c'est pas grave mais bon en fait
j'ai compris
donc ok le vainqueur de Division 2 se
qualifie pas mais on est d'accord que
celui qui gagne aujourd'hui n'a pas
gagné la division de il faut encore
qu'il vienne demain parce que il y a
c'est double élimination donc il y a
quelqu'un qui va revenir du tableau des
perdants et qui va avoir le droit de
défier le vainqueur du tableau
principal entre guillemets enfin si
Maxime de toute façon on revoit Maxime
demain et c'est ça la bonne nouvelle
mais on espère on espérait évidemment le
voir dans des dans une
fille dans une position de vainqueur et
donc de avec une une possibilité de de
mal faire entre guillemets c'est à dire
que en fait celui qui gagne maintenant
sauf la il faut le battre deux fois
demain c'est ça en fait ce qui va se
passer
c'est que bon vous savez que pour être
éliminé il faut perdre de match
le vainqueur des gagnants et ben
0 match mais si en finale la grande
finale ça veut dire le vainqueur des
gagnants contre le vainqueur des
perdants et bien si le vainqueur de
gagnant bat le vainqueur des perdants et
ben dans ce cas là il est premier parce
que le vainqueur de perdants on va
parler deux fois on a perdu une fois
pour être perdant et une deuxième fois
en finale
par contre si le vainqueur des perdants
balle vainqueurs des gagnants et bien
ils ont tout départu un match donc ils
refont un match exactement
du vrai vainqueur donc c'est un petit
peu compliqué à comprendre mais là on
commence à bien gérer on a quatre
parties avec Maximin pour dire on va
faire un coucou amical à nos amis du
chat je vois qu'il y en a un qui a très
en forme comme d'habitude notre ami
bonjour à tous et à toutes évidemment il
y a quatre parties aujourd'hui avec
Maxime Vacher Lagrave je bluffe un petit
peu je suis pas sûr à 100% mais comme
c'était quatre parties hier je me doute
que la finale elle va pas se jouer en
moins de partie ouais tu lui confirmes
oui d'accord
dans la poule des gagnants c'était
quatre parties dans la poule déperdant
c'est seulement deux ça qui est Magnus
ça fait que deux parties contre ceux et
on a une grenfeld très intéressante on
peut peut-être revenir un petit peu
Stéphane
c'est une pour une Feld avec G3 et
Maxime joue le système qu'il adore de
qui joue depuis nombreuses années qui
est et appelé le rock solide
donc voilà où on joue symétrique on voit
si Stéphane si au lieu de mp3 par
exemple on prend des 5 et bien ça ça
fait une position complètement
symétrique et donc
et donc voilà assez égal et là Maxime
sacrifie un pion mais c'est assez c'est
assez connu comme comme sacrifice on
sacrifie un pion pour avoir des pièces
plus active pour avoir une petite
pression sur le pion V2 et voilà on joue
à trois tu vois le cahier C3 devient
loose comme on dit c'est-à-dire lequel
c'est 3 si on prend à trois le cayr C3
est plus défendu et on voit le fougeret7
qui pourrait se réveiller et qui
pourrait manger ce cavalier en C3 donc
il y a beaucoup de jeux ici et Maxime il
est quand même très bien ses positions
il est comme un poisson dans l'eau hein
c'est une position très dynamique ou
vraiment il y a beaucoup de jeux je
jouais déjà ces variantes cette vente
avec G3 symétrique pour vous dire à quel
point maxime a l'expérience sur ça je me
rappelle d'une partie à l'époque il y a
les Grands Prix FFE c'était en 2008 donc
ça date pas d'hier donc Maxime c'est
clairement quelqu'un qui connaît tous
les
un petit peu toutes les finesses de ce
système qui joue depuis très longtemps
comme un peu ça gonfeld hein ça gonfne
il ajoute depuis qu'il est gamin donc
effectivement Maxime qui a l'habitude
hein qui a pas peur de ses sacrifices de
pions pour le dynamisme on va voir ce
que va faire le jeune Abdou Sator Rohff
mais c'est intéressant là il fait fou B3
qui a un coût très très concret
et du coup
du coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
noirs a priori on va essayer de ouais il
fait fou aussi ok ok donc il essaie
vraiment de d'empêcher qu'il est 5 ce
fou en 17 États en prise
il est pas pressé pour reprendre ses
pions Maxime et vous voyez un maxi
machin grave qui sur un plan comptable à
deux pions moins mais la jauge qui ne
m'ouvre pas qui donne une égalité ça
veut dire est vraiment à ça se voit que
les pièces sont très actives et tout et
les pièces blanches elles sont elles
sont quand même majoritairement sur la
première rangée
pas développée avec cette dame en 1 qui
est très bizarre donc beaucoup de jeux
pour Maxime Vacher Lagrave dans cette
première partie on verra ensuite on fera
on regardera le tableau comme nous l'a
proposé chaise comme fr salut à toi mais
c'est vrai qu'ensuite on a on a du
manuscarsen on n'a pas Fabiano carbonac
qui a gagné alors c'est sûr moi j'étais
surpris en fait la surprise hier je
trouvais c'était cette victoire sèche de
Fabio carronnaz à saikaunakamura 2 et
demi un demi et si j'ai bien compris
tout au système tu m'arrêtes parce que
apparemment je suis pas au point Fabiano
Carola ne va pas jouer aujourd'hui il a
tant le
faire des perdants
et donc il aura peut-être deux matchs
demain par contre s'il perd le premier
en tout cas il y aura deux chances de
[Musique]
un deuxième derrière donc si vous voulez
je peux vous montrer vas-y
j'ai une question pour toi Stéphane tu
sais à quelle heure joue Magnus Carson
non c'est en suivant je pense que c'est
juste après
[Musique]
le score ici donc là vous voyez
vous voyez ici
voilà comme ça vous voyez mieux donc
comment ça se passe donc là on a la
finale ici et le vainqueur de la finale
là
je vois contre le vainqueur de la finale
d'en bas la finale d'en bas vous avez
donc là ils sont pas encore vous avez
demi-finale qui est guéri contre la
zavik et la crème
vont se jouer ici pour arriver en finale
là et le vainqueur de la demi-fin de la
de la finale jouera contre le vainqueur
de cette finale là
ah non et non non je pense pas
et non parce que attends il y a Abdou sa
Toro ou Maxime qui revient dans le
braquet
il me regardait on fait quoi de de
Maxime Le
ici il y a marqué oui il vient là contre
le winner
ou mvl est reversé dans le truc oui
c'est ça ouais d'accord on est d'accord
ok
donc ça c'est voilà pour la deuxième
division pour la première division je
peux vous montrer aussi bon là je sais
pas comment ça met sur
sur
le même système c'est le même système
je crois qu'on ne perdant je compte la
caméra voilà c'est ça bon une chance de
redéfier karwana c'est ça
l'adversaire et soit adversaire et ben
ça va être ça peut être ma caméra ou ça
peut être 45 aronia etc Nakamura qui va
venir ici attendre le 24 de harmonial et
le vainqueur de cartian Aronian puis
Nakamura
affrontera carwana dans un match voir
deux matchs donc encore il y a pas mal
de choses à faire et demain donc ça sera
le dernier jour les grandes finales avec
peut-être des des revanches si les
vainqueurs de d'hier en tout cas de
mercredi donc Fabienne okawana et mvl
web de cette off se font banache ils ont
droit à leur revanche c'est ça les
privilèges du des des vainqueurs
et bon il joue pas pour la calife hors
de vision 1
mais c'est bien dommage d'ailleurs
donc comment on fait alors
elle est complexe cette position c'est
chaud c'est bouillante ici
je sais pas trop pour être très
honnêtement mais alors
on peut pas prendre aussi ça on va déjà
on va faire plein élimination quand
c'est compliqué comme ça parce que si tu
prends aussi je reprends et ensuite
j'attaquais F2 et je t'attaquer le
cavalier à 4 en plus parce que le fou B3
défend bien le pur A4 bon puis on prend
un 3 c'est un cours responsable
mais comment on va faire remarque c'est
pas mal comme ça sur cavalier prend le 5
on peut faire fou B2
ça fait beaucoup mais je récupère au
moins un quand je veux
aussi faire
[Musique]
non
mais je peux remettre une cavalier sur
une bonne case
vas-y on va bouger non on va montrer ou
tu peux pas
mais là je vais te manger aussi c'est
intermédiaire et qui Détroit et je vais
être bien quand même plus c'est un
structure
et là
j'ai un vrai pion de plus parce que en
plus toi tu es pion eux là ils sont
quand même très très faibles pour les
finales c'est quand même très très
embêtant même si temporairement tu as un
peu d'activité exactement à ta aussi une
pression sur le pion F2 mais quand même
sur le long terme ce genre de chose la
pardonne pas en général
dans les bonnes conditions et c'est
taper là-dessus
c'est pas un truc que Maxime si tu veux
va non va envisager de manière sérieuse
parce qu'il
c'est une variante qu'on regarde mais
ensuite
[Musique]
tu te dis non faut que je fasse mieux
c'est vraiment désespoir de cause
comme ça où il est moins bien
c'est la menace et puis attention ça
peut être grave parce que tu as vraiment
des pires en moi
donc pas évident pour pour mvl ici qui a
été un peu trop large peut-être dans ces
sacrifices de pions
et à d'où ça t'auras à noter qu'il a
Berlin en ce moment il joue le tournoi
je le tournoi de de la de World chef
Armageddon ouais donc il joue en c'est
marrant il y a la moitié du tournoi du
tournoi
d'Armageddon à Berlin la moitié qui joue
aussi online donc voilà pas le temps de
chômer pour les meilleurs joueurs du
monde j'ai vu ça hier j'ai regardé la
liste
c'est pas mal joué
[Musique]
on attaque le cavalier alors je je
regardais un truc mais ça marche pas on
va on va le montrer une petite
combinaison pour prendre des 7 ok B6 ah
oui tu reprends des 7 avec la même idée
de faire qu'il y a les bêtises mais ça
marchait moins bien
et oui
c'était pour prendre des 7 qui ne
marchait pas je vais avoir la montrer
quand même te reprendre essai de me
prendre et 7 kb6 tu dis liquidation mais
il y a Dame des quatre qui est embêtant
je pensais que dame les quatre étant
apparemment la jauge dit que cahier
français 8 serait pas mal encore pour
les blancs en fait je vois pas là mais
je me dis que ça va être la ligne
qu'elle prend ses 8 ans qu'elle prend
cet échec que j'avais pas vu de loin
et là même un petit coup de F4 tu vois
j'ai quand même beaucoup de pions j'ai 5
pions
ça devenait un truc raisonnable mais il
a joué qui est B6 direct qui a un coup
très logique plus simple alors qu'est-ce
qui se passe Stéphane sur dame prend V6
on reprend des 7 et qui prend le 5
menace la tour
intermédiaire j'ai compris
et ensuite tu bouges la Tour Eiffel
pas impressionné
et ouais mais il a il a il a deux pions
de moi alors un an et demi on va dire
parce que c'est des pions doublés en a
deux à trois un ennemi pion de moins et
paire de fou et il est pas moins bien
développé maintenant donc c'est la cata
pour Maxime ça va pas du tout
la bonne nouvelle c'est quelqu'un de
parti il peut se refaire derrière mais
je crois qu'il est vraiment complètement
foutu d'ailleurs on voit la mine de
Maxime qu'il est pas convaincu par son
parce qu'il vient de se passer là
attention tu me donnes tu commences à me
donner tu me donnes le 7
ben j'espérais de te faire une
découverte et bon
espérer bon après je sais pas ce que ça
vaut mais
je suis foutu donc je tente de manger le
matériel mais d'un point épaules
c'est quoi là il a une
[Musique]
mais en plus le roi devient maintenant
le roi blanc
il a quand même
cavalier
[Musique]
mais il y a des il y a des cas de
forteresses
et le roi et le roi très faible on va
pouvoir faire foi 6 et G4 voilà il va il
va essayer de faire ça mais bon Abdou ça
te rend pas impressionné et ce four en
V3 qui a l'air de servir à rien qui
quand même qui contrôle la case D1 et il
y a pas de casse d'accès pour la tour
donc ça va être très compliqué de
générer du contre-jour et là le pion
commence à foncer mais bon
de défendre tout ça et ensuite je je
fonce ils fonce ce pion à ouais
malheureusement sans les pions a je
pense que ça serait tout simplement nul
mais avec des pions a c'est tout
simplement perdant pour C8 est trop là
on fait à 5 je pense qu'il va faire à 5
bluff pas ce jeune nord du bec qui est
vraiment très très bon
toutes les cases après j'ai plus qu'à
pousser
il va faire il va calculer là c'est le
moment il a 5 minutes à la pendule on
rappelle c'est du 15 + 3 il a 5 minutes
à la pendule donc il va prendre un peu
son temps et essayer de calculer
maintenant c'est le moment de la partie
où si vous voulez les joueurs vont
essayer de calculer enfin en tout cas
d'où ça sort va essayer de calculer un
gars jusqu'au bout avant il faisait pas
mais maintenant il commence à calculer
il tac tac tac dame B7 échec assis à 7
il voit s'il est à temps pour faire une
deuxième dame et évidemment la deuxième
dame finira la partie donc il a calculé
il a pas pris autant de temps que
j'aurais fait mais voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il joue et qu'on commente et ton
c'est un roi G2 et maintenant ça y est
il va foncé
4 à 6 ça veut dire que que j'ai 4 à 6 et
tu en H3 en fait
la totale
c'est juste c'est juste fini
5 h 3 et cavalier F6 qu'est-ce qui va il
veut revenir en B7 c'est ça il va
revenir en B7 il va faire à 6 à 7 et
good luck non c'est Maxime y croit plus
quand il joue vite comme ça
quand même faut s'organiser la dame B7
c'est l'air sympa
ah non mais ça c'est sûr que tout est
gagnant mais bon
je pense
franchement de pas avoir laissé en
baisser c'est un peu décevant
je contrôle
[Musique]
continuez la partie mais attends
c'est pourquoi il est abandonné parce
que des deux
on aurait pu montrer je voulais montrer
ce fousser
donc pour ceux qui ont toujours la la
position fous ces cinq dames des deux et
en fait ou qui est avec la tour on
pouvait attaquer la le fou et la et la
tour c'est tourbé on faisait dames ces
deux attaque le fou et l'attaque la tour
si Touring vous êtes am C3 attaque le
fou attaque la tour il perdait une pièce
et on a donc mvl avec les Blancs une
freshnikov alors là ça sera c'est le F
time répertoire qui sort pour Noël
attention
Noël Noël 2020 quelque chose on sait pas
et donc il joue à keyb8
Maxime va chier La Grave est-ce que non
à 12 ans pardon est-ce que je vais
conseiller kb8 ou cavalier 7 et bien
vous le saurez en achetant le cours le
Lifetime répertoire
bientôt
mais en tout cas les deux sont largement
jouables c'est une question de style et
je vais même peut-être faire une option
mais bon enveloppe
j'ai fait ça déjà dans quelques
chapitres je fais une option tu vois
plus agressive ou plus solide ou plus tu
vois parce que là en fait on va est-ce
qu'on peut montrer la position après
prendre des 5
de cette recherche nikov totalement très
les premiers coups d'ailleurs aussi
alors et de là je suis nikov pour ceux
qui n'auraient pas la référence
on devient très dynamique très
rapidement donc il prend des cinq seuls
coups puis on prend des sacs et là il y
a deux coups soit cavaliers 7 et ensuite
avec l'idée de le mettre en G6 comme la
fait Magnus Carsen lors de son match
champion du monde face à Fabiana soit B8
comme l'a fait ma muscade dans son
machin du monde face à Fabiano carwana
voilà il a tout simplement changé donc
il y a deux options la vente avec
cavalier 7 est beaucoup plus agressive
et donc me semble voilà je lâche un fou
me semble mieux convenir à quelqu'un qui
a envie de gagner un joueur de club qui
a envie de vibrer avec son lifetime
répertoire donc on va essayer de faire
vibrer les gens hein
voilà
en fait tu fais quel G6 et ensuite tu
fais F5 dans plus tard F5 ou 7 petit
rock est à 4 F4 est un cavalier qui est
prêt à bondir en 5 et tu vois tu sens
que il y a quand même un truc qui se
profile autour du roi blanc tu vois qui
peut qui peut s'organiser et tandis que
les blancs vont jouer à une dame donc
c'est une course une sorte d'Estienne
d'ailleurs c'est la structure de
stendienne ou les blancs en gros jouent
à la dame mais nous on a pas le droit à
la dame c'est ça le truc et nous on veut
aller droit donc on va mater en premier
ou pas c'est pas mais en tout cas voilà
c'est ça le l'enjeu
alors cavalier B8 joué par abusa torov
qui est la ligne classique et la ligne
la plus solide
X2 qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu deux fossettes
ou des deux
on est pas pressé de roquet avec les
blancs mais quand même va falloir ok un
moment voilà et de la fait
il va revenir à viser la case B6
clairement et donc là les Noirs il faut
que voilà il joue le 4 il va faire fu F6
cavalier 5 si on lui donne il fait
cavalier 5 d'abord mais clairement c'est
une course même là c'est une course ou
les Blancs ont davantage central avec ce
pur en dessin qui est un avantage à
l'aile dame avec évidemment cette
majorité ce 42 à jouer tandis que les
Noirs vont essayer de monter une attaque
à l'elroit
alors vraiment évidemment pas pas
n'importe quel prix mais il faut d'abord
s'organiser pour pour défendre un petit
peu mais sur le long terme c'est
clairement le plan parce que les finales
par exemple ça aurait très très mauvaise
pour les noirs on voit déroulerait du
côté blanc du côté de la Dame Blanche
qui est moins largement jouable que
l'autre ah bah alors ça j'ai envie de
voir mon petit Giro
il est marrant il y a toujours des trucs
très sûrs très différents toi notre ami
Algérie c'est pas si possible
j'ai des copies j'ai des copies de j'ai
des sons
j'ai envoyé à Stéphane et Nathan ce
matin j'ai été moi
je te remercie disant ça fait plaisir
j'espère que tu vas bien
alors comment on fait ici avec les noirs
comment on fait pour créer cette attaque
alors Florent herbe qui nous dit je
m'avancerai pas quand même
les blancs si jamais il arrive à pousser
tout là-haut et prendre les cases etc je
vais j'ai quelqu'un ça va aller vite
mais c'est la course comme tu disais un
peu
F4 je crois pas
d'aller trop vite parce qu'on donne un
peu des cases blanches mais
comme ça
ouais ben je pense que c'est pas mal
et là tu vas donner à F2
il essaie de ralentir un petit peu le
jeu ah faut c'est 5 pour faire [__] ok
ok
pour gagner maintenant la case D4 c'est
malin et sur B4 il voulait sûrement
faire [__] des quatre attaquer à la
tour et puis après réussir à se placer
rapidement avec avec ces pièces
il faut trois pour un sport pour
empêcher fout des quatre et E3 direct
puis on prend on va on va voir R4 je
pense hein mais alors attends tu as vu
moi j'aime pas du tout quand Maxime joue
aussi vite ça montre un tilt il joue
trop vite là j'ai vécu ces scènes là ou
sur internet ils jouent très très vite
c'est très très mauvais signe après
avoir perdu une partie malheureusement
la maxime qui trouve il prend pas du
tout son temps faut qu'il fasse
attention Maxime parce que ça commence à
devenir très dangereux cette histoire et
ouais donc révolution échec qui veut
faire il veut faire des niveaux il veut
faire des progrès en anglais bon en même
temps
vu ton niveau tu risque pas de yresser
mon cher ami
on aime bien se rendre plus très très
longtemps donc on se permet des choses
alors fk3 H1 Maxime
il a pas de train à prendre Maxime
détends-toi
c'est quoi comment on fait
ouais Maxime mais attends c'est hyper
dangereux hein
par exemple tu vois si fou c'est 3 moi
admettons je joue des couleurs dedans
déjà j'ai F3 là tu vois
très très peur alors peut-être que
j'avais ouais j'avais fou des quatre
peut-être qui était meilleur que ça
peut-être mais il faut que je viens en
Détroit
et non pas ça là
il va où Kevin il a dû te raconter son
planning des vacances non hier ouais bon
comme
d'habitude
je peux te dire parlant français direct
un conseil ça ira plus vite
ah ouais alors
fais-moi mes séjours aux États-Unis les
types comprenaient pas trop donc
il va il peut reprendre du pion aussi
non éventuellement ou pas
en fait je réfléchis à aux options
est-ce que je peux pas
elle va devoir être prise
tu remets la décision un peu plus tard
mais en fait en tout cas tu vas devoir
l'apprendre cette décision donc je vais
prendre 5 c'est ce qui va vite
je pense qu'il va je pense qu'il va
manger ici dans Maxime prends ton temps
s'il te plaît
[Musique]
prends ton temps qu'est-ce que j'aime
pas quand il est un type comme ça
[Musique]
bon je montre un truc débile mais
toi F5 pour être une idée ah ça marche
bien
un truc comme ça tu vois
un truc comme ça ça fait très très peur
alors peut-être c'est pas ma tout de
suite mais attention ça va pas tarder
mon fou
j'essaie d'échanger des pièces hein de
plus en bon centre donc voilà
c'est la partie
la partie
on va voir ce qu'il va faire fout des
quatre
maxi va chez Lagrave en tout cas la
jauge aime bien bon ben elle est dure à
jouer cette position
il faut vraiment être alerte à chaque
fois
très très intéressante cette position
on a le droit d'habiter on a pas le
droit quand on joue nos parties
je préfère
on voit plus de choses
[Musique]
la tour
en C5 va pas participer à l'attaque il
semble que quand même
il y a rien du tout entre le fou le fou
tient tout peut-être j'ai pas F3
il y a dame prend tout le monde
donc ça va je pense qu'il y a pas grand
chose ah bah oui
pas fou
des quatre non seulement l'échange les
pièces parce que j'ai un plan de plus
mais en plus là je vais changer les
bonnes pièces ce fou est très dangereux
incontrôler la classe G1 du roi et on a
vu plusieurs idées d'attaque avec F3
avec tour la tour là qui peuvent
attaquer en H2
ça fait peur quoi donc il vaut mieux
vite échanger les bonnes pièces et noir
et en plus après le départ du CASE noir
et ben je peux même pousser B4 c'est 5
en fait ça va m'aider à pousser mes
pions donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
au feeling après alors Maxime il sait
tout ça vous inquiétez pas pour lui par
contre il réfléchit aux choses concrètes
c'est ça
c'est maintenant c'est l'heure de
calculer c'est ce que Maxime fait très
bien donc faut des quatre je sais pas
pourquoi des quatre il y a par exemple
peut-être fou B4 à regarder et est-ce
que est-ce que ma tour elle a une bonne
case
tours 5 je sais pas c'est une mauvaise
tête trop ça je peux faire fouter 6 et
je me serais trois derrière ou F3
d'abord tu vois par exemple tout rose 5
vas-y tout ça
F3 puis on prend admettons vous des 6 ok
ça c'est chaud c'est au minimum chaud en
fait c'est très chaud ça on sait pas
Toro 2 tours F3 enfin bon c'est pas ce
qui va se passer quoi donc ça c'est un
truc à calculer donc Maxime évidemment
il est il est dans le calcul là c'est
bien qu'il ait fait une petite pause il
m'a fait plaisir et là je tourne il a
joué tout au 5 voilà je pense qu'il veut
un truc comme ça ouais clairement et
donc là il calcule il a dû calculer F3
que tu avais
c'est quoi je crois qu'il y a
et peut-être que
le mug a été repéré il y a un mec à
gagner
c'est pas du collector ça les amis une
grande famille vous voyez je pensais pas
montrer franchement
pensez pas un jour si on m'avait dit tu
montreras un jour ce mug sur Facebook
mais comme quoi la vie la vie est pleine
de surprises
[Musique]
4 qui reste d'actualité avec des F3
encore
en fait tu sais pourquoi il me plaît ce
coup tu ressens que ça libère la case 1
aussi pour la dame créer un chantage on
peut pas jouer les finales évidemment et
on commence à avoir pas trop énormément
de cases pour la dame damage
et là qu'est-ce que je fais
quand même ta source numéro 1 de contre
jeu ça fait
[Musique]
pas mal
mais c'est ça le problème
des deux recettes par exemple
donc il faut absolument il faut
absolument faire quelque chose de très
très concret et c'est évidemment des
joueurs convenable d'où ça torov ou
Maxime machinagrave il réfléchissent pas
à ça pendant la partie parce qu'il le
sentent tout simplement
et je peux faire ton coup tout à l'heure
aussi dans F2 pour menacer ma tante un
coup de bouger mon choix
plutôt un E2
parce que fout des trois F3
mais ça fait peur en pratique t'as pas
trop envie de ce genre de coup non par
contre faut deux contrôle bien
ça peut être une énorme blocale
c'est fini alors on va update pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent il y a un zéro pour
Abdou ça torov malheureusement ah oui
c'est pas mieux avec avec le jeune nord
du bec Abdou Sator qui a ouvert la le
score très belle partie dans la première
il est un peu encaissé le matériel de
Maxime espérons que Maxime fasse la même
chose dans la revanche où il encaisse le
matériel de dehors du bec pour l'instant
ça semble pas mal parti pour pour une
égalisation un peu dans le même style ou
les Noirs je vous dynamiques mais les
blancs refusent calmement
mais attention c'est pas fait
je sais pas ce que je jouerais là avec
les Noirs honnêtement
F3 en fait ce qui m'a fait peur tout à
l'heure c'est G3 et j'ai trois tu vas où
aussi
tu vois tu vas tu as pas trop de casse
pour cette table si tu fais dommage si
je fais Dame des deux
et en fait je te ce chantage est
absolument ce chantage à l'échange de
dames et quand même assez assez
désagréable pour les vraiment
générale je vais avoir quatre pions
contre deux ici et la barre de fou qui
va nous aider à pousser ça a l'air très
très dur pour pour noir en plus bon il y
a aussi du matériel d'avance un peu plus
donc exactement et bon on a là encore
c'est une meilleure version parce qu'on
a le plus en F3 avec les Noirs mais ça
même comme ça ça perd de suffire
j'ai plus trop d'attaque on a
l'impression
d'être pas mal aussi
moins de 4 minutes parce qu'il sait très
bien que il doit gérer son temps et
simplement en incrément de trois
secondes par coup donc ça suffit pas
pour pour jouer une position aussi
complexe face à un peut-être le meilleur
calculateur au monde le meilleur
tacticien au monde Maxime va chez
Lagrave
qui reste quand même au sommet de son
art niveau calcul il impressionne
même même manuscarsen très impressionné
par
mvl niveau tactique
donc je sais pas je pense qu'il va jouer
F3 en fait tu as rien de concret il faut
que je prends parce que c'est comme la
ligne où tu vas le plus ouvrir la
position blanche est-ce que je peux pas
faire tout va vite aussi peut-être
essayer de finalement cette tour en E5
elle défend bien je trouve
pas bien apparemment mais bon moi je ne
comprends pas pourquoi
mon micro est là
par rapport à toi c'est ça un petit peu
Kevin pas mal d'accord ok Kevin il était
moins fort que toi
pourtant il parle plus fort
Kevin était moins fort
parce qu'il faut qu'on se mette à ça
change à ces histoires de son d'un jour
sur l'autre la clinaison du micro si ça
a bougé de 2 mm
ça peut tout changer toujours pareil
mais n'hésitez pas à nous dire s'il y a
un problème de son il a joué à Dos
Santos
tu te dis cette tour en C8 elle attaque
pas du tout je vais changer cette tour
en E5 qui me qui me gêne un petit peu
quand même dans mon attaque donc je suis
à coup que je peux comprendre sur damer
j'ai peut-être fou F2
en vrai
peut-être ça marche
en fait je peux je peux à la F3 avec
Madame en fait je peux aller un peu où
je veux
pas l'air d'être d'être le coup de
l'année c'est pas une réputation non
plus non tourage 5 c'était quand même
l'idée de tout ça tout à l'heure
il va venir en F2 mais tu as vu comment
Maxime il joue et je concret hein
regardez dans F2 on va on va calculer
avec Maxime mais en bougeant les pièces
nous c'est plus facile la meuf de fou
des trois c'est ça qui veut
et comme ça
maintenant on entend un peu moins
Laurent que Stéphane tu vois je t'ai
rééquilibré mais ouais je pense que
c'est bon là même moi j'aurais mis à 25
mais bon
là ça va être bien
ok tourage donc h6 il y a eu donc il est
venu tu vois en fait alors jouer tout
revu d'abord et ben ça empêché faut deux
parce que maintenant il y avait donc
problème alors on aurait pu y aller j'ai
pas eu le temps de la montrer mais elle
était jolie cette variante on va avoir
la montrer vite fait sur au lieu de H6
si on faisait 6
on faisait tout reprend ici avec les
plans et surprend H7 et 7 et tout ça
échec croisé 8 et mat au prochain coup
pas d'un projet 6 donc faut faire très
attention en fait c'était Maxime
t'as vu c'est quand même la
contre-attaque éclair c'est typique
Maxime ma chère ça c'est la spéciale et
sur H6
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on joue ici les deux fous
braquer cette tour qui est quand même
bien placée là on a un weekend de plus
calculer
mon premier mon premier réflexe c'est de
meuf allez
non mais attends et tu sais que je crois
que tu peux pas tu peux pas l'éviter
l'échange de dames
tu vas où dame 3
tour
et
[Musique]
je crois que tu sais c'est bon ou pas
mais non
le premier réflexe en tout cas moi mon
réflexe est de regarder ça
me fait plaisir
waouh attends mais attends champion
effectivement
je vois pas je vois pas la jauge semble
indiquer quand même un gagnant
mais alors je ne comprends rien
attends
Tour Eiffel
et on voit on voit aussi qu'il y a quoi
trouver Maxime il l'a pas Maxime il le
sait pas il faut prélever
alors que le fou on sait trois contrôle
la case de 1 donc si le foot par la haut
et ben déviation je m'attends en fait
c'est hyper faim
et le petit le petit coup sur Maxime
dans ma faim encore une fois je te l'ai
dit
de toute façon c'est ce qui va être joué
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'il fasse
d'autres
Tour Eiffel
dame 3 dames 3 c'est la partie et
surtout prends F6 on va montrer tout est
fin de 3 fois
je t'attaque la tour et surtout je
contrôle la caisse G6
c'est un coup assez
assez grosse prise de risque en fait
dans une position où
bah tu as une position qui est très
bonne tu as un peu plus tu peux juste
peut-être lire défendre la position et
après
placer des pièces échanger les pièces
mais en fait elle revient par E5 tu vois
c'est ça le truc
c'était le coup qui est plus direct qui
est qui plus concret quoi peut-être
mater mais je pense qu'il a complètement
raté pour réussir ça va être le fait que
le chantage sur le coup part et ben il y
a le match du couloir et maintenant
Tour Eiffel dame 3 c'est la position de
la partie ouais on s'arrête après
ah non il y a encore nul
je pense que là en fait il a pas trop
si la chose Montréal
ah non pardon
elle montrait également
foutu
un maximum
les émotions d'hier aussi
compliqué à gérer tout ça avec ces
problèmes
c'est tweet ce petit énervement bon de
zéro pour pour nordy bake Abdu sa torov
je crois qu'il y a une petite pause
je crois qu'on va en faire on va en
faire de même pour pour que tu me fasses
tes petites pubs ouais alors attends de
finir ça
reste avec nous ensuite après Maxime il
y a Magnus et il y a Manu je pense qu'il
joue deux matchs aujourd'hui
je crois bien ouais s'il gagne
évidemment le premier on le souhaite
il peut il peut jouer on peut avoir un
Magnus Nakamura quand même donc ça vaut
le coup de rester je crois qu'on a un
Magnus Aronian et le vainqueur de Magnus
Aronian joue ensuite contre Ikaru
Nakamura et celui qui gagnera entre eux
bon j'ai envie de dire ça sera Magnus
Nakamura et donc le vainqueur de Magnus
Nakamura jouera caroanna demain on dort
la grande finale et ensuite faudra qu'il
battent deux fois Fabiano Carana pour
l'emporter ça sera pas évident mais
c'est pas impossible mais ne
sous-estimons pas Fabiano qui a gagné la
division 2 du 1er tournoi là qui qui
gagne tous ces matchs en fait tout
simplement
on le sait il est moins on va dire
normalement moins fort que ces joueurs
comme comme Carlsen et Nakamura dans les
cadences bleat c'est rapide sur internet
mais en 15 + 3 tu as quand même plus tu
peux quand même plus jouer d'échecs et
bah hier franchement le match contre
assez propre
donc
on revient tout de suite
à tout de suite
pour la pour la pub de hercy ça arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
imaginons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour la
troisième partie de de ce match avec un
adaptateur de qui
mène 2-0 donc
une nul pour adultes
du deuxième de la deuxième poule mais ça
veut dire qu'on peut retrouver Maxime en
début de soirée du coup parce que Maxime
de la première division
mais après dans la deuxième division il
y a encore du monde ils sont encore en
demi-finale malheureusement dans les
perdants donc on sait pas encore ma
question est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'il
rejoue si hyper il rejoint aujourd'hui
quand même
alors ça il faut que je te redise parce
qu'en plus j'avais attends je l'ai pris
en photo
et Maxime qui a pas du tout jouer une
Feld on voit une structure ça sent ça
plus la ragosine cette histoire
aujourd'hui
on a une division les loosers
[Musique]
on a la finale voilà
la deuxième division et on a là quart de
finale demi-finale et finale
donc ça veut dire que il rejoue si il
perd maintenant il rejoue la finale
c'est ça non bah super oui parce qu'on
joue adversaire et rejoint un peu plus
tard en fait pour vous compreniez tous
la la diffusion 3 elle se termine
aujourd'hui demain on va voir que la
grande finale de la Division 1 et de la
division 2 donc tout ce qui se fait
autre que la grande finale ce sera
aujourd'hui
donc on aura tout on aura
on aura tout absolument tout
salut Marius
salut à toi salut à tous colline du
printemps aussi qui est là rejoint donc
c'était quoi le début ça m'intrigue un
petit peu est-ce que c'était une
ragosine ou une mère en une semi-slave
alors on va regarder on va regarder
et voilà Maxime qui a changé
il a besoin de deux victoires Maxime
Vacher Lagrave il a joué une ragosine
avec ce système très très solide pour
les blancs c'est pas casser la tête
Abdou sa torov et bon voilà bon Maxime
qui obtiennent une position
il reste des pièces pas de variante
forcée
c'est ça c'est ça l'idée
et la paire de fou quand même sur le
long terme bon pour l'instant elle est
pas elle est pas glorieuse cette paire
de fou mais on sait jamais B6 fu B7
voilà B6 jouer fou B7 ensuite si ça se
réveille tout ça ça peut être pas mal
pour les noirs
[Musique]
il donne l'occasion à d'où cette offre
de déjouer de s'énerver de chercher un
truc concret et de finalement détériorer
sa position au profit de la paire de fou
de Maxime donc c'est ça a l'air d'être
ça me plaît comme choix d'ouverture
c'est un bon choix et puis pour appeler
aussi que qu'il a qu'une nul à attirer
de partie donc voilà si c'est un petit
peu trop
Maxime
encore donc là c'est une position un
petit peu déséquilibrée il y a quand
même la paire de fou pour la noire
contre le centre des blancs donc voilà
c'est un peu ça les bails pour l'instant
et donc ça a été joué d'ailleurs bon je
fous baisser
et peut-être plus tard essaie d'ouvrir
un peu cette colonne des avec un C5
tout à fait normal les Noirs les Blancs
d’œufs s'organisaient déjà contre ces
contre ces poussées peut-être un coup de
fou alors en Détroit ou en F1 pour créer
ce vis-à-vis un tour d'âme qui est
toujours toujours dangereux pour la dame
donc
ça se fait sinon je vois pas grand chose
d'autre un coup de G3 aussi pour
tout simplement
je me dis que sur le long terme ça peut
faire peur ouais mais je peux mettre mon
fond en G2
pas te manger et puis
t'amélioré ici une carte de catalane
et puis après ramener la dame peut-être
de vis-à-vis
et ils vont un peu ce qui se passe et là
on a souvent des coups d'ailleurs comme
comme C5 pour cette bloqué V7 c'est
bloquer la poussée la poussée noire en
C5 qui permet de vous ouais alors un
petit il y a un commentaire dans le
format sur le format boréabo Goris qui
dit que déjà ça
c'est on a un tournoi d'un très beau
tournoi alors après le format aussi les
nouveaux donc c'est comme toutes les
nouveautés tu vois au début on nage un
peu mais je pense que d'ici
ou deux tournois et l'année prochaine
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui s'inscrit dans la durée et bien je
pense qu'on y verra très clair
là on est un peu perdu parce que c'est
nouveau mais en fait voilà moi aussi au
début je t'avoue que le premier jour de
l'événement et même avant je connaissais
pas trop trop le format et puis bon
maintenant ça va j'ai commencé à bien
comprendre l'expliquer 30 fois depuis le
début la compétition donc voilà mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas un format qu'on
a l'habitude de voir donc c'est un peu
bizarre mais
en fait voilà c'est pas si c'est pas si
difficile en fait
juste tous les gagnants gardent leur
[Musique]
comment appelle ça alors parcours normal
vous savez
alors que chaque perdant passe dans un
dans une
poule de constante inférieure on va dire
mais dès que tu perds deux fois c'est
terminé et après les joueurs vont se
retrouver à la fin de la boucle
peut-être que mais peut-être qu'à la fin
à la au bout du bout ils font un truc de
d'élimination directe sèche voilà il y a
sur direct à l'ancienne c'est possible
ça se termine comme ça après c'est un
essai sympa ce double élimination ça
permet de et bien de donner voilà de
d'éviter les mauvais jours chez un
joueur avec une élimination et de donner
pas mal de piment on voit Magnus Carlsen
c'est genre discutais avec Peter qui est
le qui est le coach principal de Magnus
c'est vrai que cette première défaite
face à artemiev a créé un challenge
quand même assez incroyable parce que
maintenant il faut qu'il battent toutes
les sauts il faut qu'il battent les von
aroniaques ça c'est déjà fait il a du
battre les coins viennent il a battu
wesleaux il faut qu'il battent
aujourd'hui à rognanakamura et ensuite
il faut qu'il va deux fois karwana je
veux dire le challenge est quand même
très très beau et bon pour l'instant il
y en a deux sur 6 on va voir on va le
suivre évidemment il est évidemment
capable de faire 6/6 mais ça donne un
challenge pour les joueurs aussi très
très
excitant et assez nouveau
après on part de la caméra de dubstor
off alors je vous rappelle qu'à Abdou
ben il est il est actuellement en
Allemagne il participe à un tournoi en
IRL et donc ton portable on imagine donc
ouais c'est pas la la c'est pas la
grande
la grande qualité sa caméra mais bon bah
on fait avec les moyens du bord hier on
a vu cramique de son téléphone donc bah
voilà comme on peut j'ai envie de dire
c'est vrai que voilà ouais car club qui
le résume très bien et les joueurs en
devis
quand tu fais tout le monde a joué a
fait un ping-pong avec des tu tournes la
tendance là tourner en toping pong voilà
tu as tu à chaque fois tu gagnes tu as
une vie donc tu utilises ta vie et puis
tu rejoues tu rejoue voilà
alors est-ce qu'il faut que je m'éloigne
de mon micro c'est ça non mais moi je
suis bien proche de mon micro on est on
fait ce qu'on peut là à côté de moi je
pense qu'à la même distance du tien
ouais d'accord mais
faut que je leur explique mon système
ouais qu'on puisse pas monter de
division franchement ça c'est vrai que
c'est un peu bizarre alors du coup non
les les divisions sont indépendantes la
2 1 2 3 non rien à voir ensemble c'est
dommage ouais c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu
avoir une une qualification pour la
première place mais non c'est pas comme
ça et en fait les califes pour
déterminer les les poules enfin les
joueurs dans les poules se font aller
ici le tournoi qui sont qualifiés online
voilà
tu as participé le coin Laurent
participer au premier il y a 7 places
d'une calife au départage ce fameux
départage mais bon de toute façon ça
aurait été à l'arrache mais tu auras
très sympa à jouer
alors puis on prend des cinq maintenant
il va faire que ces trois a priori où
est-ce qu'on peut faire prendre 5 il
fallait quand même se mettre en face de
de détour donc prendre des 5 c'est un
truc il faut quand même bien regarder
hein
parce que ça il y a une découverte mais
là en fait on voit bien qu'il y a pas de
bonne découverte enfin ça sert pas mal
pour venir attaquer le pion des cinq
mais vous voyez que sur un chèque là je
m'enlève de du vis-à-vis et puis j'ai
pas trop enfin je suis pas sûr d'avoir
des assez de choses après qu'il y avait
des seins qui se regardent quand même il
y a du foie htérieur il y a des tiens tu
vas où sur quel
F6 peut-être
j'ai cru que sur DMF 6kh7 avait plus de
casse mais tu as des cas sur la 6e tu
peux aller maintenant
j'ai peut-être du foie H7 bon moi je
suis tu voyais quelqu'un fourchette donc
là ça marcherait pas la dame ici j'ai
qu'un droit est cuite encore qui va
tenir mais ça fait un peu peur même un
tour aussi ce qui pourrait être arrivé
on sent qu'il y a du il y a le potentiel
il y a du potentiel d'attaque là c'est
pas que là mais
ok il a requé cette croix Dame des 6 là
il y a quelqu'un qui a aussi la prise en
dessin qui a très très bonne
alors qu'est ce 3
lames des 6 OK et maintenant on va
prendre du
pion aussi avoir cette combinaison très
connue évidemment on va la montrer
peut-être puis on prend des cinq faut
prendre des 5 et prends qui serait
malheureux à cause de cette découverte
attention attention à ce thème très très
connu mais
qu'on peut se prendre si on fait pas
attention à ce niveau là ça n'arrive
plus quand même non oui
la dame est protégée
j'ai voulu mettre une couche acheter une
couche de 5 pour manger avec une pièce
et un canal mais j'ai oublié qu'il y a
on prend et la dame dépend du parc le
foudon je rappelle que nous on travaille
vraiment sans ordinateur ça se voit ça
se voit
c'est vrai c'est vrai non et puis c'est
bien pour vous parce que vous vous avez
nos réflexions en temps réel et c'est
bien pour nous aussi
parce que ça rend le truc plus
intéressant et plus vivant plutôt que de
pour lire pour lire des lignes d'ordi
hein vous avez vous avez pas besoin de
nous tout simplement
je prendrais plutôt du pion parce que ce
soit un vaisselle j'ai l'impression
qu'il est pas terrible quand même et
après il y a le côté footlo reposer
après qu'elle prend des cinq aussi qui
me plaît parce que après tout on a
besoin que que du nul donc elle prend
des cinq faut prendre puis on prend et
ensuite voilà ça reste quand même fou de
quoi reposer ok M6 peut-être un autre
thème qu'on va montrer Stéphane c'est
après fou c'est 4
vas-y prends prends non la vente qu'on
montre
alors je voulais montrer ce petit thème
avec un autre thème tactique très connu
qui est fousser 4 qui prend des cinq
il faut prendre des cinq dames prendre
les 5 et tout 8 et voilà c'est encore un
truc c'est un pattern c'est pas un truc
que je vois en une seconde en fait c'est
un truc que je connais qu'on a vu qu'on
a vu stéphane et moi des centaines voire
des milliers de fois et qui a du
matériel surtout en 8 si on ignore avec
roalcet on fait dame prend des cinq
maintenant
ce thème là avec la tour qui prend la
tour à Moroni
de Vienne et il avait 2005 quasiment moi
j'avais 2002
donc c'est pas bon du tout on peut pas
manger maintenant toujours toujours la
même en couleur on va dévier la tour des
fois la dame et c'est la tour s'en va à
la dame sera emprise et d'ailleurs aussi
qui est toute seule donc son bouche de
l'orage je mange la dame ce qu'il a
dévier cette tour là et nous permettre
de ramasser à toi
c'est thème tactique à connaître tout
simplement
pour gagner du temps
et on menace ici j'ai l'impression qu'on
me fasse G2 G3 qui est quand même très
très embêtant il y a plus trop de cases
pour le fou comment il fait maximum il y
a deux choses
il joue assis donc il laisse G3
ça c'est peut-être
c'est jouer
si ça va pas l'air c'est moche mais bon
c'est chaud là je pense que là mvl il
est pas un chemin assiette aujourd'hui
mais clairement pendant son assiette
donne la pièce
donc il a pas le choix et il est un peu
de jeu c'est le fond à deux je joue pas
et il espère un cahier prend des 5 la G6
comme tu l'as dit le roi est ouvert mais
effectivement on le sent que ça va pas
être assez
juste pour vous montrer l'idée que là il
y a du
mais là c'est pas bon ouais il y a tout
reprend des sacs
j'ai plein de choses qui peuvent arriver
mais bon
comme ça en fait on voit qu'il y a quand
même du jeu donc là je pense que
c'est pas un coup qu'on va voir
non alors on nous dit dans le chat que
Magnus a commencé vous inquiétez pas il
a commencé on va aller voir de toute
façon cette partie de de ce petit
matelas je vois pas mal je ne vois pas
Maxime malheureusement
gagner cette partie et salut François
qui est François
c'est même frame de François
femme de François d'accord
alors on va aller voir évidemment vous
inquiétez pas Magnus beaucoup de fans
à travers toutes ces années ou à répéter
que Manu c'était le meilleur bien bien
aidé par les résultats de Magnus quand
même qui tentent à démontrer cette
théorie avec une régularité
métronome alors qu'elle prend fou prends
et maintenant faut faire attention à ce
cavalier F3 CEDAM G6 qui peut arriver
[Musique]
c'est très dur à jouer
et qu'est-ce qu'il a joué du coup
c'est pas bon donc là il menace
7 mais c'est prendre ça
a été raté par Maxime mais attends je
peux pas manger là
non
mais pas de la bonne pièce je contrôle
toujours deux fois dans ma tête je
pensais avoir le matelas haut avec la
Dame des sceptre avec la même idée que
tu as donné sur dame par H3 et dame
prend des cinq maintenant elle marche
cette déviation
et tout va vite
on vient de voir l'idée et après
pour se défendre un peu et ça contrôle à
4 G4 surtout
même matin
pareil par exemple est-ce que je peux
faire J6 ici enfin un coup qui me donne
une casse pour un roi pour mon roi G6
donc maintenant je me laisse un proche 3
et fous.f3 enfin je me laisse à peu près
tout et maintenant que je voulais blanc
ici ah tu sais ce que je voulais blanc
ici il joue autour des deux
cauchemar pour Maxime
tu prends le tu prends le four et au
mieux avec tes échecs tu auras perpète
mais de toute façon j'ai gagné et en
plus je pense que j'aurais mieux que
perpète a
prioriage
aussi
une pièce
ouais alors quelle année il prend pas
son jour pour Maxime et pour l'instant
il a fait un
il fait quand même il fait il fait un
beau tournoi là il avait tout gagné
jusque là avec l'impression qu'il a le
match d'hier l'a mis un petit peu tu
vois il a commencé le match ça c'est mal
et puis attention il joue pas
il joue à perdre de l'année entre
guillemets si tu veux avec ça d'où ça
trouve qui est quand même nouveau sur la
scène mondiale mais il arrive tel il
météorite et franchement on a parlé il
est dans nos deux top 3 des des futurs
probables numéro un mondiaux champion du
monde
il est quand même c'est un client très
très sérieux
là on voit que même là vous voyez il
mène de zéro il est hyper concentré
hyper focus G5 avec tes jouets alors ça
c'est desperados de Maxime
et sur dame ces deux il fait quoi Maxime
qui pourrait nous expliquer ce qui fait
sur M6 qu'on l'a très fort des deux
je mets la ce matin
j'ai envie de voir je pense qu'il est
obligé de jouer F5 il y a le tour de doc
bon c'est fini les carottes sont cuites
pour maximiser la grave
et il croit plus du tout et ça sent même
moi
qui va arriver quand je veux bien que ça
défend sur H3 tours tout de suite dame
prend des 5 et tout 8
je pouvais même tout manger et faire vos
quatre à la fin
[Musique]
qui qui va se retrouver en finale demain
contre c'est pas encore qui peut-être
d'ailleurs contrainte vert c'est
possible parce que mvl enregistre sa
première défaite du tournoi donc il est
pas encore out on va devoir qu'un film
j'ai pas mal de demandes tu as vu il est
parti il est parti à 12 ans enfin il y a
pas de temps à perdre de toute façon il
joue un tournoi ce soir enfin bon
il a une vie il a une vie occupée il est
né occupé ce garçon alors attends je
vais t'installer la caméra pendant un
peu perdre si tu veux parce que il est
nouveau mais il est quand même il est
quand même il est quand même très très
fort champion du monde de partir rapide
en 2021 et attention au champion de
partir rapide il y a tout le monde il y
a les raisins il y a Magnus il y a des
pots il y a ding oui il y a peut-être
pas digne cette fois là vous pouvez pas
sortir comme d'hab mais mvl enfin bon
c'est c'est la croix et la bannière moi
je les ai joué c'est champion du monde
assez rapide je peux vous dire c'est
même même quand on a 50% en fait
ça joue il y a gris chou qui company
enfin c'est toujours l'enfer on va aller
voir Magnus qui joue simplement deux
parties contre les von a rognanes donc
ça va être intéressant de voir
aller-retour dans ce il a plus le droit
à l'erreur Magnus Carlsen
contre son adversaire les von a rognanis
connaissent très très bien les deux
joueurs ils ont joué des des dizaines et
des dizaines de parties ensemble
notamment un match des candidats en 2007
rendez-vous compte ils ont déjà joué
ensemble que les von a rognan avait
remporté au bises de départage donc
c'est une vieille histoire entre les
deux il y aurait dû entre guillemets
l'histoire aurait voulu que Evan Aronian
qui a été numéro demandé par de
nombreuses années et un match de
championnats du monde face à Magnus cars
7 mais l'effones arrondiales a toujours
craqué à la dernière à la dernière
marche des candidats
il a mené les candidats mais toujours il
s'est il y a toujours raté le coche et
voilà ça aurait été ça aurait été mérité
sur l'ensemble de la carrière d'aronian
d'être challenger au titre mondial mais
ça n'a pas été c'est comme ça
non du coup elle vient elle a gagné
contre cramique hier c'était
rocambolesque mais finalement Vladimir
cramique a laissé la victoire entre
guillemets parce que elle était méritée
cette victoire de de Maxime Vacher la
graff bon c'est pas grave pour Maxime
on va voir en parlant de Ding et de Ding
et de machinalement on vous rappelle que
ici même à partir de dimanche vous
pourrez suivre ce match de championnat
du monde entre digne des reines et Yann
et pomiyashi à 11h heure du Kazakhstan
j'ai vu déjà les photos des deux joueurs
les deux joueurs sont sur place ça sera
un beau combat et un nouveau champion du
monde à l'issue de ce match
à suivre évidemment en direct avec les
images et tout
donc on va voir ma muscarsent qui allait
il est blanc dans cette partie on est
d'accord ouais
on peut reconnaître la variante
c'est miche
de la défense nimsovic avec ce coup à
trois
et
position très complexe ou un bon centre
blanc et on a un pion de plus non si je
vois bien
je suis pas sûr de tu mets au mauvais
endroit là je crois non non
pardon donc Magnus qui a l'air d'avoir
un pion de plus net
et l'attaque c'est pas mal hein tu as
toujours un peu de jeu pour les noirs
avec ce pion en C4 qui est faible mais
franchement
tout ça très ça a l'air très sympa pour
les blancs
donc on va voir on va voir ce que ce que
nous a prévu les von toujours un deux
parties simplement sur 15 + 3 on va voir
les cames on a les droits on a les
droits
il est en train de les mettre teck texte
et femme c'est d'où son silence il est
concentré sur sa mission là je vois là
il est fait bien il est bon il est bon
texte
il est là on est bon ouais
vous allez avoir vous allez voir les
deux joueurs
apparaître sous vos yeux éveil
c'est bon ils sont là
donc ces deux parties de parties avec
éventuellement en Armageddon qui va qui
va arriver
donc c'est la même ligne qu'on a vu la
dernière fois on a on avait parlé les
blancs qui ont tout le centre contre sa
structure noire et notamment ce petit
pion en saccade qui peut un jour être
sous pression avec un cest 5 fois 6 on a
déjà parlé il y a quelques jours si vous
avez suivi sur le stream avec Laurent
par là effectivement on parle de
beaucoup de choses
c'est vrai que
c'est encore quelque chose qu'on n'avait
pas encore cette pollution pas encore
parlé
généralement le roi quand même il va OK
alors tout est F8 alors comment on fait
avec ce roi moi c'est un truc qui
m'angoisse mais je sais que ça angoisse
pas les joueurs de ces miches donc toi
ça va pas angoisser le roi non donc ça
va mais après j'aime bien quand même les
positions sécurité est-ce qu'on va
est-ce qu'on imagine un coup droit des
œufs ou c'est
pas roi des deux parce que je protège
madame et en fait sur X 6 ah oui parce
que tu exagères un petit peu je vais
essayer de te punir je vais faire
cavalier H5 je pense pas que tu puisses
faire d'av4 en fait dans ma 4 t'as pas
d'entrée t'as pas d'entrée mais on va
regarder
la G6
j'hésite pour prendre G6
[Musique]
est terminé et mais sur mon idée de roi
des deux c'est non seulement de de lier
les tours de faire coulisser la
l'autre tour et aussi sur fois 6
maintenant j'ai protégé madame un E3
donc ça veut dire que je peux faire
cavalier F5 c'est l'autre coup que
j'avais envie de jouer cavalier F5 et
donc du coup ma dame est protégée tu as
plus de tours F5 parce que j'ai pu en
prendre et mon roi on voit l'utilité du
courroie des deux qui protège la dame et
donc après kf5 c'est quand même chaud
pour les Noirs tu vois on n'a pas envie
de on est peut-être pas mal tout de
suite mais on n'a pas envie de voir ce
cavalier venir F5 donc je sais pas ce
que va faire Magnus roi des deux est un
coup qui me viendrait mais je sais pas
j'aime pas cette position de toute façon
avoir un roi avec des pions devant et si
possible sur le côté est-ce que alors
c'est une question que
ça fait un peu mal de personnes
je te préviens à l'avance ok mais je
pense que beaucoup d'argent aussi donc
un peu inconfortable avec un roi au
centre généralement tous les pions
avancés
est-ce que si on avait le droit en H1 ce
serait une bonne version de la position
oui merci Moreau
serait quand même pas mal ouais donc
tous les faire tous les faire coulisser
le temps de faire des choses quand même
il y avait le petit pion en C4 qui est
en plus par exemple
[Musique]
qui est vraiment
je peux pas dire c'est recomposer en
fait mais tu vois le roi blanc il est au
centre les blancs qu'une belle attaque
un gros centre mais le roi il est là
c'est vraiment une position très
compliquée je pense qu'on a pas trop le
temps d'aller cacher le roi alors vous
savez que le roi c'est plus important il
faut le il faut le défendre à chaque
fois
mais c'est vrai qu'ici la potion elle
est hyper ouverte et j'ai pas de temps à
perdre en fait
dans la protection de mon roi donc il
faut vraiment partir à la table il a
juste ces cinq
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fait c'est 5
pour pas le perdre dans ces quatre jours
est-ce que maintenant
comme des 5 serait possible
j'essaie de punir le cavalier
[Musique]
moi je suis un peu de Graber comme on
dit
j'aime pas du tout ce je prends le pion
au moins
au moins il va manger
je peux pas te bluffer niveau des pions
je sais que si jamais je donne des
plombs tu vas me les manger ouais ouais
ça c'est le site de la Maison
ouais ce sera district et son équipe qui
vont qui vont commenter ici sur sur
chaise come fr ouais le championnat du
monde
[Musique]
et ton G5 aussi
on veut jouer la petite finale à quoi il
y a le pur F3
au coup de sauce que le 5 est une
d'abord F2 garde tes pions
passer en E5 là
c'est la position là
F4 il laisse pas le pion ça c'est ça je
te le garantis ils sont pire que moi
énervé je viens il me regardait comme un
fou au départ je te jure première
session entraînement ils m'ont dit mais
tu fais exprès de laisser tes pieds en
prise ou tu vois pas en fait comment ça
marche quoi et j'aurais dit bon je suis
pas là pourtant j'ai pas l'impression
mais c'est les
c'est sûr c'est sûr et il y a notamment
yo notre vie amer alors lui il est il
est incroyable il te regarde et il
demande si tu sais compter quoi vraiment
c'est à ce niveau là et que tu donnes un
pion il donne pas les pions donc le
style norvégien c'est tu laisses rien
donc il va pas laisser F3
il est en train d'analyser F4 au F2 mais
rêve de 3 et hyper tentant ça a l'air
tellement facile alors Roy F2 qui est 6
pour aller en E5 méta tours j'ai 5 OK
donc le 5 s'attaque là j'empêche surtout
de 5 c'était l'idée de tourges 5 et je
me suis tourné un qui a la ça va en fait
ok j'ai une autre idée au lieu de au
lieu de faire cavalier 6 je fais faux
aussi
sur ton coup de ouais
non non
j'essaye de m'activer tu vois si tu
prends C5 je prends des trois je vais
prendre F3 donc ça ça va aller
si tu fais pousser deux c'est jamais
très agréable tour D1 et puis en a deux
et tu peux jouer au 3 éventuellement
mais roi est-ce que je vais pas vous
est-ce que j'ai pas quelque chose comme
ça ou cavalier c'est 4 et
c'est pas est-ce que je suis assez c'est
exactement ça Magnus Carlson évidemment
qui réfléchit à aux conséquences de ces
de ces coups
donc c'était annoncé ici F4 était
l'autre option mais trois si ça marche
tactiquement avec ce coup de fou aussi
ce tour des 8 où je que sais-je
d'ailleurs ça peut être tourbé 8 tour B2
aussi c'est quelque chose de dynamique
quelque chose d'actif pour les Noirs si
ça marche concrètement pour les blancs
les blancs sont gagnées parce qu'on a
comme tu l'as dit 3 et puis on a ses
pions c'est doublé alors on a plus de
temps de plus mais c'est comme si en
fait parce que on voit on a un purpassé
on a pu repasser quand même sur la
colonne E bien protégée par son collègue
en F donc c'est quand même c'est quand
même très sympa sur le papier pour les
blancs
et ce qui va jouer Levan les 25 janvier
tu vois il essaie de chercher le truc
alors ton G5
allez-y maintenant à mon avis il y a
deux coups ah non mais non il y a deux
coups de 50
donc en fait il y a un seul coup c'est
la partie
qu'est-ce qui se passe autour des deux
ça va envie de faire tourner
bêtement mais je pense tu fais pas ça
qu'elle prend pour penser 5 j'ai essayé
des deux j'étais très embêtant je menace
le pion F3 évidemment et il y a un
menace cachée OK prend 4 avec ce clouage
de la tour est fuite rêve de là je vais
me faire attention
et en fait sur foubet 5
c'est 6 au début je refais juste fois 6
en fait
OK
[Musique]
donc ça a pas du tout
et sur Full j'ai encore trop
c'est ça
pour les Noirs c'est chaud quand même tu
vois c'est pour ça que il fallait
calculer bien concrètement ce qui se
passait surtout
pour me
lancer
trop bien donc là les von évidemment il
est conscient tout ça et il faut qu'il
trouve un coup un coup très dynamique
tout simplement qui crée quelque chose
pour sinon il abandonne dans trois coups
voilà c'est simple que ça donc s'il perd
le pion c'est 5 et que les Blancs ont le
temps de faire et des quatre il
abandonne
équivalent donc il faut qu'il fasse
quelque chose de de très rapide il se
passe quelque chose
on a non non il y a une question très
très intéressante
j'encaisse le BG qui nous dit j'ai
commencé l'échec sur cheesecom il y a
deux mois avec 500 et l'eau maintenant
je suis 950 combien de temps ça me
prendra pour reach le 1300 €, mais ça ça
dépend de ton investissement
de ton travail de ta fréquence de jeu et
de ton talent mon cher voilà
et de tellement de choses
on peut pas il y a pas de il y a pas de
cas qui se ressemblent
après je sais pas peut-être que tu as
une réponse plus éclairée que la mienne
non mais je suis d'accord
c'est que chacun est différent en fait
c'est pas parce qu'il y en a un qui a
réussi à faire tu vois à monter je sais
pas 300 points hello en un mois puis en
fait tout le monde va réussir à faire ça
quand même travail en fait c'est
important de bien voir que chacun est
différent et tout ça mais c'est clair
que oui là tu as gagné beaucoup de
points haut c'est très bien maintenant
après 1300 ça commence à être déjà un
niveau qui est un petit peu au dessus
et j'ai envie de dire quasiment genre de
club tu vois 500 900 euros c'est encore
débutant comment joueur de club
alors que 500 900 c'est plutôt débutant
tu vois et donc passer 1300 et l'autre
ça commence à être à être une belle
barre quoi donc après bon c'est pas une
admirable hein loin de là loin de là
mais nous en sommes des preuves vivantes
voilà j'espère pas ouais mais voilà
juste c'est un peu prendre plus ou moins
de temps ça dépend comment
investissement ça dépend de de plein de
choses et puis voilà donc maintenant
avec le contenu qui a sur internet avec
tout ce que tu peux avoir c'est vrai que
tu peux facilement
il y a pas mal de stream il y a des
chaînes YouTube
[Musique]
beaucoup contenu sur Internet
ça c'est sûr et on voit il s'est décidé
pour assis il a fait quelque chose de
très actif les vans hardyan sur ces
derniers coups on a un peu
merci cette question
ce contre jeu et ce ce vis-à-vis je
trouve que c'est c'est hyper créatif
tous les trois cavale
il cherchait quelque chose d'actif mais
alors est-ce que ça va suffire ou pas
sur ces quatre on va faire fouber tout
simplement c'est pas un joli coup à
jouer mais de toute façon c'est la seule
case pour le pour le fou petit à petit
je sais de me remplacer de chasser tes
pièces et changer les pièces
en fait vous voyez que si on échange
toutes les pièces la fenêtre de roi la
gagnante pour nous parce que j'ai un
pion passé
alors que toutes les peaux noirs sont
très très faibles etc donc en fait le
but des blancs c'est de d'activer
d'échanger les pièces au maximum pour
simplifier la position et attention les
blancs les blancs sont clairement
dominants comme tu es très bien expliqué
et aussi autant regarde moi ça 15
secondes pour les voies naronian qui est
quand même dans le dur là qu'est-ce
qu'il a joué les von il a joué quoi il a
joué C4 non je sais pas
tu vas nous le montrer Stéphane pardon
[Musique]
je te le dis c'est sa priorité il a six
secondes contre 3 minutes pour
manuscrite
évidemment sur ksc4 qu'est-ce qui se
passe est-ce qu'on fait tout reprendre à
deux pièces pour la tour ou est-ce qu'on
a un plus immédiat
je peux le montrer ton idée
C4 pour clouer
plein de choses en prise donc là je sais
pas si ça vaut le coup de te faire
cavalier de même si j'ai envie mais ok
ça va être joué trois il fait tourner
vite d'abord comme tu l'as dit c'est
assez simple
et ensuite je mets un pion H5 je mets un
caler un F4 et j'ai une structure
complètement intouchable
tour à 3 h 5 d'abord et sur ah non c'est
5 pardon je gaffe je gave je gave je
fais n'importe quoi je dis n'importe
quoi donc comment on fait ce que je peux
jouer alors je vais pousser deux d'abord
réfléchit comment il va organiser tout
ça
j'ai l'air très concentré un manuscrit
je trouve qu'il est beaucoup plus en
forme que que l'autre jour
et sur ce 5 tu as juste ok des seins qui
peuvent arriver des fois
je lui récolter les pions et je vais
pousser
c'est le plus facile c'est ce qu'il a
fait un cours c'est un jeu
je pense là ça va être abandon
est-ce qu'on peut ouais ouais
il y a pas abandonné tout de suite il va
jouer comme ça
[Musique]
non non
tu veux te prendre la tête alors non il
veut faire
peut-être ah oui ça pète
il cherche toujours la petite bête c'est
toujours
[Musique]
deux trois deux
je te pose encore deux trois questions
sur ton C4 je fais roi G7 comment tu
t'améliores comment ta meilleure ta
position c'est pas si évident tu vois
mais bon royal
[Musique]
c'est terminé c'est terminé carottes
sont cuites pour les vannes
je peux changer sans problème
je crois garde les pièces
je me
prends une un petit clouage peut-être
proposé F4 me semblait plus net mais bon
après
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'autre match on va voir derrière
mon chat parce que c'est la porte
je te laisse organiser avec ta compagnie
avec tes animaux domestiques apparemment
donc Magnus Carson c'est quoi c'est un
chat quota
d'accord ok
très bien et donc ouais faut laisser
respirer et donc voilà on a un manuscrit
à gagner après à partir on rappelle
malheureusement la défaite de de Maxime
Vacher agrave sur le score sexe de 3-0
les voleurs qui aura toutes ces chances
de prendre sa revanche enfin en tout cas
qui doit remporter cette partie et
l'Armageddon nécessaire peut-être on
verra
et ensuite on a on a le vainqueur de ce
match qui affrontera Hikaru Nakamura
pour une place demain
en finale en grande finale face à
Fabiano carwana dis donc ça nous ça nous
promet et on aura le retour aussi de
Maxime HLM un peu plus tard je sais pas
exactement à quelle heure
mais ça sera très certainement après ce
match là je pense on sait pas contre qui
mais on va le savoir bientôt parce que
Nathan il suit tout et je peux regarder
aussi sur sur le site d'accord
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que moi je la joue un
petit peu vous voyez un petit peu relax
j'aurais pas sur le site je sais pas où
c'est qu'on regarde ce truc mais
je peux vous mettre le lien si vous
voulez
je vais faire un petit coup un petit
coucou pendant que tu
parles de ça un petit coucou sur Youtube
génial vos émissions les flics merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
au Maxime ok bonjour sur Youtube on
vient vous voir de temps en temps pas
très souvent sur chaise 24 en français
et chaise comment en français n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner aux chaînes comme ça
vous ne ratez rien un petit pouce et ça
s'abonner ça coûte rien et un petit
pouce bleu
pour mettre des likes ça fait plaisir
toujours donc n'hésitez pas à le faire
évidemment sur la chaîne twitch
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner nos réseaux
sociaux et comme ça vous ne ratez rien
de tout ce qui se passe donc
[Musique]
voilà voilà pour les nouvelles et ce
chestable Masters n'hésitez pas à aller
voir nos sites de chasseable qui est de
plus en plus complet avec des nouveaux
lifetime répertoire des aussi c'est tout
en anglais mais bon l'anglais est chèque
comme tu disais l'autre jour Stéphane ça
reste quand même très simple des milieux
de jeux des final on peut tout
travailler on remercie nos amis nos
sponsors de rings Puma tout le monde
vraiment la grande famille ça fait
plaisir qui nous permet d'avoir un beau
tournoi et aussi d'aider
on va pas se mentir un d'aider les
joueurs d'échec professionnel on voit de
70 joueurs qualifiés 70 joueurs qui qui
font un prix mine de rien et donc voilà
ça permet c'est aussi je pense la
volonté de cheescom à ouvrir ce truc de
Division 2 divisions 3 qui est un peu
compliqué à suivre mais c'est aussi une
aide précieuse pour les joueurs d'échec
pro
et donc bah voilà on est je pense que
c'est plutôt pas mal parce qu'en fait ça
soutient tous l'écosystème ça fait que
des commentateurs sont payés ça fait que
ceux qui jouent là ils vont pas jouer
d'autres open ça fait que ceux qui
jouent là donnent pas de cours donc ça
fait plus de plus de boulot pour les
profs enfin bon c'est bon pour tout le
monde c'est bien pour tout le monde
c'est tournant
le confinement déjà bon il y a beaucoup
de tournois Magnus tu sais et c'est là
en fait que les les autres joueurs
professionnels et ben avait du mal à
tournoi aussi et à gagner de l'argent
entre ces gens professionnels qui jouent
pour moi qui vivent des tournois et
c'est vrai que pendant le confinement il
y a eu des gros problèmes avec beaucoup
de joueurs qui ne pouvaient pas
travailler et là c'est vrai que ce temps
dans la base il y a quand même pas mal
de gens qui ont 2600 hello 2500 hello
qui peuvent se qualifier et participer
et gagner pas mal d'argent donc c'est
vraiment intéressant c'est pas que le
top niveau bon c'est quand même très
très fort moi je prépare qualifier mais
mais c'est pas non plus le top 10
mondial quoi c'est ouvert
je te remercie mais
je reviendrai mais moi je pense que si
je me qualifie je me permets de
cheeseccom quoi
donc on demande depuis où joue Magnus il
joue depuis les Alpes françaises je lui
prête mon chalet de 500 mètres carrés
évidemment
avec barre
à bulle évidemment à chaque dans chaque
pièce voilà donc les Alpes françaises il
adore la montagne le triple champion du
monde encore pour quelques semaines et
donc il fait des petits randos et il
vient se divertir aux échecs
l'après-midi non mais il est dans une
situation tournoi voilà où il y a le
voyage et tout ça il se met dans le mais
dans le mode je joue un tournoi d'échec
et donc je voyage et je trouve ça pas
mal
en tout cas c'est intéressant c'est je
sais pas si c'est une bonne idée ou pas
mais en tout cas c'est quelque chose
comme souvent avec Magnus Carlsen quand
il fait quelque chose
c'est souvent intéressant et à réfléchir
alors
comment on va de la jouer à rognan ici
qui doit gagner cette partie C4
surprise qui prépare la panoplate
voilà et puis on prend des cinq étaient
possibles aussi mais là on va jouer
cavalier F6 les blancs vont jouer KS3 je
suppose et on fait qui est C6 en général
est-ce qu'on fait connu pour être mou
donc il y a full G5 ici qui est
un peu étonnant
B35
d'abord et de m3 ensuite Magnus ancienne
a joué la maison ouais
je sais pas
c'est ça ça fait selon la théorie ça
fait c'est à peu près équilibré
j'ai pris F3 c'est j'ai pris F3
aussi
simple qu'elle prend des quatre il faut
baisser 5 échecs
Dame des 7 et cette position elle donne
elle donne je crois des chances assez
égales
léger très léger pour les blancs mais
sur un jeu précis évidemment les Noirs
font nuls après Magnus Carlson je vais
fouger 4 il a joué dans ce tournoi
online il a joué à cette assise contre
Aniche Viry ah bah tiens c'était en
situation il devait gagner mais il le
répète tu vois et G6 c'est un autre coup
aussi qui existe mais à 6 quand je
l'avais vu je me suis j'allais le
regarder ce truc là mais je l'ai pas
fait mais je me suis c'est marrant et ça
a l'air intéressant et ok à 6 à toi de
jouer
c'est un peu le concept je veux faire
fouger 4 au prochain coussinet dame B3
très gênant sur MP3 j'aurais cavalier à
5 ensuite et donc
il en profite pour se restaurer un bon
appétit au champion du monde quelques
semaines
donc oui il est bien en France c'était
pas une blague il est vraiment
en France
alors à 6 en Haute-Savoie comme comme
qui
c'est c'est vrai
c'est ça
mais pas ça
non désolé
Brassens
tu me fais c'est Cabrel c'est vrai après
le Cabrel le Brassens
pas tellement parce que c'est ça que tu
fais fouger 4 et tout de suite il y a
une grosse pression sur le sur le pion
des 4
qui donc
pas sûr après c'est une option
clairement c'est ça qui est clairement
une option mais pas forcément des Fuger
5 ouais aussi plutôt fous de 5 je trouve
ça donne envie de faire
ouais parce que la ligne dont je parlais
au lieu de cavalier F3 c'est fou G5 et
clairement à 6 cavalier F3 est un coup
qui aide les blancs comme A6 et pas un
coup qui est vraiment les Noirs
donc faut j'ai 5 et intéressant et
fouger 5 fois aussi jouer tout de suite
par Magnus Carlsen
donc il connaît ses petites variantes
attention il y a réfléchitours
maintenant normalement on essaie de se
développer donc il y a deux coups
candidats ici pour les noirs sont fait
cavaliers aux quatre soit j'ai 6
fougères
va taper sur le pion des quatre siens
j'ai 6 jouets
tu vois que ça arrive
[Rires]
et en plus j'ai dit j'ai dit Brassens
derrière il l'ont pas encore mais c'est
incroyable que je dise
en plus
moi j'aime bien la musique que j'aime
c'est la corrida ah ben ça c'est
original tiens ouais
par tout le monde comme sa meilleure
chanson tu vois
j'adore non mais je connais quand même
Cabrel
que je passe
alors
juste après c'est toujours une
impression que que la voix française
Cabrel avec son accent on a un petit peu
alors peut-être tu vas de moi mais il y
a un maître français
qui a le Couvin la même voix que lui
et le français
il y a 2400 tours à peu près toute sa
vie
plein de clubs il habite dans le sud de
la France
je crois tout zen
il me semble
peut-être pas de fac mais de grands
trucs
peut-être non il pue
il y a un petit ensemble et c'est vrai
que tu fais tu fais un trop gros
compliment
ils sont tous même à 100 ensuite c'est
bizarre que tu sois mais c'est pas le
vrai Sud enfin bon c'est pas vrai
c'est
un peu je sais pas
bon je sais pas non je trouve pas alors
oui mais je parlais juste de l'accent en
fait et
[Musique]
un accent toulousain qui est quand même
très marqué
par Magnus et on voit les vans qui
réfléchit beaucoup dans ce début qui est
surpris et il faut absolument qu'il sait
très bien que si il pense pas de souci
particulier à Magnus dans l'ouverture ça
va être très compliqué c'est très
compliqué qui se passe quelque chose
dans cette partie
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait envisager ici
d'être un petit en fait un moment donné
en fait se poser la question de savoir
si on peut quand même manger l'option C4
c'est pour ça que sur petit rock tu sais
pas possible non tu manges là tu fais
des seins peut-être c'est ça
je compte sur ça en tout cas parce que
si j'ai pas ça c'est foutu
est-ce que je comprends je trouve les
Blancs ont raté leur ouverture et
peut-être de ces cinq de cheeseccom fr
était
mieux
les pièces comme fr ouais ouais
déjà qu'il est il a le Boulard parce
qu'ils sont montés en Top 16 en équipe
tellement la balle perdue tu sais
complètement gratuit non non il y a même
pas parlé il ajoute au
trop modeste c'est louche c'est vrai
qu'il est sage en plus
tard maintenant
il est bien Magnus déjà sur foot3 on va
montrer la petite combinaison qui est
très très classique c'est qu'elle prend
ses seins ici et on se libère de tous
nos problèmes sur tu reprends c'est ça
qui a des quatre et on voit les deux
fous qui joue magnifiquement bien placé
c'est fou aussi fougères 7 au moins pas
de problème pour les Noirs dans ce genre
de position donc sur cavalier E4 il peut
non seulement pas prendre le 4 parce que
sur pion prend le 4 ensuite le pion des
4 serait en prise
il peut pas jouer fou et 3 donc ça veut
dire que les les
options sont quand même assez réduites
il joue quoi je peux pas laisser les
pousser parce que
peut-être qu'elle va les prendre des
cartes c'est pas encore clair peut-être
parce que je peux pas manger 6 c'est pas
forcément
oh regarde le piano
pour garder un petit peu mais c'est vrai
que tu as c'est pas c'est pas grave
[Musique]
et est-ce que maintenant j'ai pas fougé
4 qui met qui rajoute une pression
supplémentaire sur ce pur en D4 ça a pas
commencé à devenir critique cette
histoire
c'est pas ce que tu en penses
maintenant je peux je peux toujours
pas où j'en sais rien
d'abord je peux
montre juste j'aurais au moins ça qui
allait ok pour les blancs au minimum ok
donc ce qu'on fait le sens inverse
il faut voir qu'il y a des vis-à-vis
aussi de partout là c'est un peu ça
qu'il faut calculer en fait
qui était en prise par toutes les pièces
qui va revenir c'est un problème
cheescom donc on voit tous les jours
quand on fait des puzzle Rush et si je
prends des cartes et là je peux manger
en E2
et je gagne je gagne une pièce ce qui
veut dire que sur vous j'ai 4 x 3
[Musique]
il faut encore regarder des choses
ouais bon
[Musique]
elle est perdue
à part le tour à 7 mais bon moi mais
attends
tu fais quoi
alors donc
là tu veux manger F3 ou faire tourner
en plus j'ai des possibilités de faire à
ça peut être une bonne chose
tout à fait
donc ces choses ça quand même pour
normalement j'ai pas d'échiquier live je
suis désolé
sur chaise 24 mais c'est vrai que ça a
pas l'air d'être la méthode chez spa
alors je sais pas j'en avais mais je les
ai pas utilisé ou c'était pas rentré
mais j'aurais pu la voir
tu aurais pu l'avoir donc c'est un choix
en fait faudrait faire des je sais pas
si vous faites des enquêtes tu vois
auprès des viewers ils préfèrent
il était quand même assez
[Musique]
assez populaire parce que à leur vitesse
tu vois pendant qu'on analyse donc c'est
quand même sympa mais bon
ça peut se faire aussi
faut voir la vie générale aussi ça aussi
ça met beaucoup d'échec
j'ai plus de personnes j'ai même la
scène avec tes grandes caméras on ne
voit pas
aujourd'hui je sais que les gens
n'aiment pas trop généralement ils
préfèrent nous voir ouais mais est-ce
qu'ils ont préféré ou pas j'ai
l'impression plutôt que oui mais je suis
patient
oui on a quand même quatre caméras à
mettre
plus un échiquier grand et un petit
si on met les chéquiers en petits on
doit enlever des trucs donc si on enlève
précisé je pense qu'on va avoir
tout le chat qui qui va se mettre en
colère
et si on m'enlève moi ça va être ça va
être
ça peut passer
[Musique]
c'est compliqué en fait
on peut enlever enfin on peut pas
enlever les joueurs et puis après nous
on peut nous enlever mais c'est vrai que
généralement quand on nous enlèvement
vous demandez à ce qu'on revienne donc
c'est pas forcément
de mon vécu en tant que
commentateur il y a si tu prends 10
personnes dans le chat il y a il y a
vis-à-vis différents c'est ça
tout seul tu as plus de place au théâtre
bon après bon il a pris du Fou en des
quatre
je pense qu'il vaut aussi pointer le
pion c'est ça on a vu l'idée de caballer
B6 et cette tour en A7 et peut-être
qu'avec le pion ces cinq là qui sera en
prise 2 fois c'est l'hiver intéressant
c'est une amélioration
il y a du E5 qui peut arriver
j'aime beaucoup faut prendre des cartes
j'ai l'impression que c'est sympa
c'est la partie
on va voir on va voir ce qui va décider
les von compliqué très complexes cette
position
avec des chances pour les deux côtés
mais les Noirs ont quand même l'air très
solide et 4
il sera commenté par Kevin Bordy sur sa
chaîne Bitcoin
je suis quasiment sûr c'est sûr là
franchement je suis plus sûr ouais donc
c'est ici que
ouais
pas forcément tout seul je pense qu'il y
aura du sucre
du Mazet du du Étienne ouais quatre
chefs
du monde qui passera
donc B4
qui protège le pion C5 et on peut pas
manger en B4 évidemment parce que il y a
le il y a le fou des quatre en prises je
peux pas défendre là et en plus manger
donc le 5 a été joué qui défend le fou
quand un moment attaque le fou
[Musique]
je sais ce qui peut arriver il y a aussi
du Fou des deux pour défendre des cartes
comment est-ce qu'on
fait
une grosse [__] pour être honnête
alors reprise il va jouer fouder deux je
suppose il faut H6 qu'est-ce qu'il veut
faire
[Musique]
de ça non je pense pas tu as un prénom
j'ai la tour qui va revenir en jeu si je
mange T5 mais c'est vrai que j'ai pas
besoin de prendre sur L'Escala alors que
j'ai une superposition un peu plus mais
même ça sera intéressant mais
normalement il va quand même partir vite
on pense et
c'est de garder un peu ces chances quoi
d'ailleurs la jauge elle aime pas quand
je fais tourner
à trois peut-être tu sais ça peut être
ça peut être compliqué ou je protège en
B4 à 3 était malheureux parce qu'il y
avait peut-être fou B2 mais ouais il
fait qu'il prend mes quatre parce qu'il
avait peur à mon avis on peut le montrer
rapidement surtout au 8 dame B3 par
exemple mp3 c'est pas facile après pour
les noirs de sortir cette tour à 7 donc
il prend les quatre au moins une façon
claire de bien de de clairement de
régler tous les problèmes
c'est la partie alors juste je suis
curieux je mette l'ordinateur parce que
franchement
c'est une grande une grosse différence
et ma venue sans manger facilement
c'est la partie a été joué et des trois
arrivent à ça en l'air il y a ça en
l'air
pardon avec la case F2 parce qu'une fois
que c'est dommage 4 il est quand même
trois pièces tu rêves 2 le cavalier le
fou la dame c'est quand même pas mal
hein
MP3 mais vas-y on peut on peut faire des
choses
mais après j'ai pas de meilleures
solutions tu vois je suis là de faire la
morale
[Musique]
faut être imaginatif non je pensais à un
damaca pour essayer de faire
ça pour le cavalier des 7 qui peut un
jour mais bon je pense quand même alors
moi je suis on va montrer quand même
l'idée qui est des trois surtout C2 on
peut pas prendre en C5 parce que
il y aurait pour penser 5 quoique il y
aurait encore dame sera encore correct
mais là ça perdrait la dame si on prend
c'est ça je prends là je perds
ça me laisse un peu gigoter quand même
la caloche c'est quand même très
raisonnable pour les Noirs mais c'est
vrai qu'on peut faire beaucoup mieux
de dames damascar
dans ce pion en C5
ça fait
j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
un petit peu
c'est pas le seul
c'est pas pourquoi il n'aime pas
peut-être parce que je peux
un coup un peu stuff
mais je pensais à F4
là
quand tu dis non mais tu sais quoi je
peux peut-être jouer MP3 à mon avis
mais bon
vous voulez
si tu manges là je mange là
et je veux en fait d'avoir du jeu voilà
ça que j'ai [__] qui fait très très
mal quand même
après
c'est le roi il empêche c'est vrai les
chèques en 17 c'est une amélioration F3
avec des jeux dans le guider
encourageant il voulait aussi essayer de
pousser le Pure F pour ouvrir un petit
peu et sur E3 bah il va figer un peu la
position sur 15h vous voyez
donc peut-être que
j'aime bien être figé comme ça un
capture passer en E3 c'est comme ça
[Musique]
elle est pas évidente à jouer cette
position
pour la qualité
pour commencer il y a deux pions donc on
est même pas en déficit matériel
et un troisième qui est quand même en
cours en cours d'être pris alors qu'il
est 3 il va faire pour C2 évidemment et
maintenant Magnus il a dû voir quelque
chose peut-être qu'elle prend ses 5 ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure tu sais avec
on tombe dans le piège et prend ses 5
tours français 5 et dame prend B6 et 20
fois c'est un troisième pion et ensuite
je vais e43 tu bouges ta tour quelque
part je m'en moque en fait je regarde
même pas où tu la bouche et je fais au 3
frimove quasiment E3 tu vois
et
monstrueux il est là ramenez la tour et
ça fait ça fait vachement peur
donc il faut qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il a
joué
[Musique]
F2
je mange la dame la différence c'est que
pour l'instant je peux pas le faire
parce qu'il y aurait qu'à Valier c'est
en F2 et là bon j'ai encore un programme
quand même il faut prendre
mesdames et messieurs
et ouais superbe français 5 quel talent
et attention je masque cavalie F2
maintenant en plus si tu fais un coup de
cavalier cavalier A4 c'est quoi je me
fatigue pas je fais cavaliers
je peux plus bouger et maintenant B5
fidél4 comme ça on en parle plus comme
ça peut-être
la vie est très très belle il a mangé le
cap direct et
on veut
je pensais
F2 dame prend D1
tours F7 échec intermédiaire et je viens
de faire une gaffe Roger 8
rang 6 surprend ton programme faut que
je rêve de contrôle exactement
et est-ce que je peux pas quand même
manger ce cavalier
il y a ça tu me dis là
je pense
c'est 5 tours
on arrive 7 par exemple à ma place donc
ça tourne là et cavaler échec avec rien
en forme Magnus déterminer cette
position on ne perd pas ici avec les
Noirs tout simplement je sais pas si on
gagne mais en fait on s'en moque vu
qu'il a gagné la première et c'est vrai
qu'il y a des chances de sur ah à tour
de cette par exemple
OK et maintenant sur kd5
comment il va faire
8 qui est par C
pourquoi est-ce que tu veux jouer
alors qu'il va faire le coup valable
ouais je crois là franchement il y a
qu'un coup
il joue pas tout à 8 ah oui et là il va
en plus on va être sur le cul là
je crois vraiment
pour défendre
[Musique]
en fait parce que si les blancs bougent
la tour bah ils perdent là si bouge le
cavalier je vais sortir et me lancer des
trucs et si tu dois pas
bouger il veut faire A4 à trois
à ce moment-là je te fais il y a un
moment où je vais te faire un fou des 4
tourbé 8 et B5 et je m'en sortir comme
ça ok comme ça
donc la B5 a Tourcoing ici donc il va
bien
[Musique]
puis ensuite je vais 5 à partir
et ça courait quand même très vite mais
bon
contrôler
à 7 maintenant je suppose
la Bonne Nouvelle on va voir on va avoir
un cartel Nakamura
c'est même pas la finale en finale dans
la famille qui les attend ça a joué un
il y a eu cavalier à 7 pour D8 H4
c'est pas mal
ok alors une idée des blancs peut-être
que c'est ça
le matin
non non ça passe pas mais
bon il essaye
G4 déjà
c'est embêtant je veux pas qu'elle va
laisser 6 cavalier B5 peut-être
il y avait les B5
en fait il peut pas l'empêcher les
rois G4 j'ai fu1 et
juste en fait oui
c'est un gros chantage c'est un chantage
à la nul écoute ça fait c'est le jeu
dans cette situation de match
ça va être une victoire pour le champion
du monde manifestarsen
alors après cette partie est-ce que une
petite pause on commence à se passe avec
un aka est-ce qu'il offre scène direct
est-ce qu'il y a un match entre temps
c'est à moi qui demande là je sais pas
je parle tout seul je te pose aussi la
question je crois que je sais où tu
crois que j'improvise un truc ou pas je
ne sais pas je me suis peut-être que tu
pouvais savoir je regarde juste mon
petit tableau
il y a une petite pause et ensuite il
joue
la firmes
aussi sûr que le vainqueur de Division 2
vous allez voir s'il y avait parce qu'en
fait si tu veux dans les dans les
perdants
et bon on a encore là il y a encore des
matchs
en train de jouer là
comme
ce que je vois un
que à la base sur le tableau que j'ai en
face de moi je vois guéri contre
laservic et cramique contre
apparemment
cramique ben non il a parlé
ça veut dire qu'il a perdu contre non
voilà normalement il est out et là les
les demi-finales des perdants de la
poule 2
serait
[Musique]
en train de se jouer j'ai pas d'accord
donc ça sera pas tout de suite
pour voir mon tableau
bon toute façon bon attends la fin de sa
brosse à pas tarder à se terminer trois
secondes pour les vannes qui à l'agonie
là qui a joué thoréen un peu de
notre affaire pour empêcher ce fou hein
pour montrer mais bon c'est pas un coup
c'est pas un coup d'attaque clairement
il essaye de faire durer la partie la
bien raison les vans fou c'est 5 menaces
font F2 je suppose fouf 2 qui n'a pas
été paré par notre ami even alors est-ce
que F2 arrive ou qu'il prend le 5 il
faut calculer toujours pareil
faut calculer aussi
il y a pas il y a pas qu'un seul coup
qui aime bien sûr
50 secondes faut pas faut pas craquer on
veut le Naka Carson oui mais alors pas
de métal bien sûr qu'on va voir le Naka
Carlson
mais on va quand même laisser les autres
joueurs se souffler un petit peu
et notamment Magnus qui vient
d'enchaîner
enfin en tout cas qui aura joué un match
donc il aura au moins une demi-heure de
pause
ça c'est sûr on verra ce qu'on aura à se
mettre sous la dent pendant cette
demi-heure qu'est-ce qu'il fait
à la découverte il fait [__] tête les
bonnes
il va perdre il va perdre G3 et sûrement
la tour derrière c'est après voilà il y
a une découverte donc échec E5 juste un
truc de quarantenaire c'est fan de quand
tu es complètement foutu qui te reste
quatre secondes d'avoir la flemme
d'avoir donné de te laisser tomber ça
m'arrive des fois ça t'arrive d'accord
ok ça fait plaisir c'est ce qu'il vient
de faire là donc je me suis dit j'ai les
mêmes réflexes que les vans mais en fait
dans un
match très contrôlé je crois qu'on sera
d'accord
sans entrer dans cette cette première
finale des perdants pour après ouais on
a ouais ça va être beau
et le gagnant affrontera Fabi demain
en quatre parties peut-être deux fois
peut-être dépend on l'espère en tout cas
pour le pour le
expertise ou peut-être ton opinion sur
sur le match carlsan Naka je pense que
tu es tu vas me dire car ça ne va gagner
tu es un perversé
évidemment parce que Carlsen quand il
s'inscrit dans un tournoi depuis 10 ans
il est favori ouais ça marche comme ça
mais n'a qu'à attention elle a battu au
speedchais en finale j'avais commenté en
direct d'ailleurs avec avec Peter lécaud
c'était le jour de français Argentine
disant on a pris la double moi j'ai pris
la double douche c'est dur cette journée
je m'en souviens un final de coupe du
monde celui de Max du Saka mais c'est
vrai que globalement n'a qu'à Magnus a
tendance à un avantage sur la casse ça
c'est sûr il gagne plus souvent mais n'a
qu'à montrer qu'il pouvait le battre et
on se rappelle de la grande finale du
premier de champions
et Magnus avait gagné quatre à trois
donc rendez-vous compte à quel point
c'est serré donc Magnus favori mais
pas de beaucoup pas de beaucoup alors
après tu sais quoi moi je trouve que
c'est match Carlson Nakamura il est
quand même il dépendent beaucoup de la
forme de Magnus ouais j'ai vu la contre
les von
tu sais quoi c'était quand même c'était
du grand carcène donc je pense que
Magnus est très favoré après j'ai
l'impression quand même en fait que je
me trompe mais j'ai l'impression que
plus la cadence allait longue plus
Magnus devient favori quand même bien
sûr bah oui bah d'ailleurs il y a quand
même il y a quand même 13 ans en
particulier ou 14 ans je sais pas
combien mais oui le plus ça cadence
Magnus évidemment
mais bon ça reste de partie de rapide
Nakamura quand même le vent en poupe ces
derniers temps
Magnus favori mais bon match quoi bon
match qu'est-ce que tu veux et on a un
maxime a perdu mais il va rejouer
il va rejouer il a perdu 3-0 contre
Abdou ça torov qu'est-ce qu'on fait
c'est un petit break et on revient on va
voir un peu Nakamura il est sur le zoom
vous voyez la caméra sur le stream ça
veut dire que ça va jouer
d'accord donc 5 minutes on revient
à tout de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on est de retour avec la partie qui
vient de commencer donc on a une petite
carrocane avec des trois tiens
donc Nakamura elle est blanche j'ai
enfin réussi mon
flip au hasard
qui a préparé clairement Laroquette pour
aujourd'hui et cette variante cette
variante qui transpose tout de suite
dans une finale qui est une petite mode
autour de ça donc clairement Hikaru
je pense qu'il verrait d'un bonheur
Armageddon donc il va pas il va pas
tu vois handicaper ses chances en
prenant des risques fous avec les Blancs
clairement Hikaru plus le match dur plus
il est content donc plus il pense qu'il
a des chances et je pense que c'est
raisonnable parce que cette Armageddon
avec cette phase chaos
à l'avantagé donc
il va être très solide avec les blancs
avec les noirs on va voir si Magnus va
réussir à faire quelque chose avec les
Noirs bon ben du ça pas de raison d'être
vraiment contre une nulle avec les Noirs
mais
on va voir on va voir tout ça comment le
jeu va se développer mais ça risque de
jouer ça risque de jouer solide
[Musique]
pour venir consolider avec F3 c'est vrai
que souvent le cavalier ici il est mal
placé à cause du pion en 4 qui est sous
pression
et
on peut le mettre en D3 ensuite ce
cavalier il va il va bouger on va
peut-être faire un C3 roi C2 qui avait
les trois un truc comme ça
alors à voir est-ce qu'on commence par
KFC 4 c'est toujours les mêmes questions
il y a des coups de A4 aussi pour
prendre de l'espace pour éventuellement
aussi à 4 pour faire coulisser la tour
en A3 et aussi une idée et faire juste
cette tour manuscrit ferme la fenêtre et
non il joue B3
dans les Alpes françaises
18h45 et oui c'est vrai
non mais ça m'intéresse pas en fait
c'est genre d'histoire ça devait pas du
tout c'est pas jaloux
une fois
vraiment
moi aussi j'aime beaucoup à la plage
tout ça l'hiver
est-ce que tu t'es est-ce que tu t'es
déjà fait la remarque
quand est-ce que quelle était la période
d'année qui était la meilleure pour toi
pour moi c'est très très clair je joue
beaucoup moins bien d'ailleurs j'ai même
sur la il y a un moment de ma carrière
où j'essayais de jouer au minimum
l'hiver et de garder de d'enchaîner plus
des tournois pendant les pendant l'été
parce que tout simplement
je remarqué que j'avais bien meilleur
résultat l'été et le printemps quand il
faisait beau ok non moi je me suis
jamais posé la question et je pense que
après je joue beaucoup plus qui a été
écrivait il y a beaucoup de tournois il
y a plein de peine c'est vrai qu'un
hiver généralement tu en fais un quoi
enfin moi qui qui est accès aux tournois
pendant les vacances scolaires
je fais qu'un tournoi à Noël quoi
quand je peux en faire
donc
maintenant je me souviens pas la
question je pense que
pareil
plus ou moins plus ou moins plus ou
moins bien
et donc ces cinq jouets intéressants
pour développer
ce cahier des oeufs il serait il serait
tout simplement perdu donc on peut pas
le faire donc il joue sur une petite
micro tactique voilà le fait que ce coup
C6 c'est 5 soit
possible et qui est ici c'est vrai que
c'est une plus belle case que que des 7
et ensuite on prend envisager une fois
qu'il sera en prise ce pion on pourra
jouer B7 B6 et donc protéger ce pion ça
a l'air d'être une ouverture très très
réussie de la part de manuscrite je sais
pas ce que tu en penses je préfère
je connais pas trop cette pause mais bon
après moi je prenne pas mal de filibur
c'est comme ça donc c'est final là
justement c'est à peu près comment
passer en place la pièce
généralement on a tendance à plutôt
mettre puis en C2 enfin Laurent C2 et
peut-être même il y a du ou C4 ou du
cavales aussi pour garder la case un peu
comme Anastasia
et c'est vrai que B3 c'est un petit peu
étonnant mais écoute je n'en sais rien
du tout
et
[Musique]
là c'est ça en fait ça
comment tu fais là je comprends rien il
va aller où en fait la grande question
je me couche tout seul en fait
c'est un coup très très risqué ouais tu
donnes toutes les cases tu il y a des
cloises de partout tu vois et tu as
l'impression que je sais pas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui est pas le choix s'il
arrive à faire F4 G3 tu me diras et tu
vois tu me laisses de coup tu fais j'ai
trois fougères finalement ça a l'air
quand même pas mal pour les blancs
[Musique]
pas avoir de chantage comme je peux
l'avoir sur là c'est pas bien mais ouais
mais tu sais à quoi je pense du coup tu
m'as donné l'idée
et
ça peut être très très chaud parce que
attention je menace de gagner du
matériel qui est français ça toujours
pas possible à cause de fou.f4
derrière donc tu arriveras pas à bouger
les deux Caval enfin les deux pions en
même temps en fait donc peut-être il
faut dépendre le pion le pion F4
peut-être
ouais mais
ça c'est pas si clair
franchement je suis d'accord c'est
bizarre ouais c'est bizarre
oui il voulait faire ce plan on l'a dit
j'ai trois Fougères
et oui le fruit de mes il y a un
troisième là la fin du mois là je joue
plus hein j'arrête vous inquiétez pas à
la fin du mois là il y a encore il y a
un petit bonus pas lourd deux points
deux points qui arrivent mais bon on les
prend c'est mieux de les gagner que de
les perdre
ça va faire trois mois trois mois
consécutives en ressort c'est pas des
hausses dingues mais c'est des petits os
c'est quoi
la tendance est plutôt à la baisse non
j'ai fait j'avais 622 j'ai gagné 4 et 4
et là je gagne 2 moi j'ai gagné 10
points tout en Bundes
elles sont pas jojo les parties du matin
mais il est parti du samedi sont très
corrects
à ton niveau c'est quand même beaucoup
cette saison de Bundesliga a été un des
meilleurs tournois depuis ces dernières
années j'ai joué dit parti père fin 2016
je gagne 10.1
je c'est suffisamment rare pour être
apprécié voilà donc et il joue ses
cartes ton coup sur ça Gaspa ouais et
bon
quelle est la pointe peut-être cavalière
tu
vas pas être déçu
tu vas voir
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué sur ces quatre
Hikaru il réfléchit
ça veut dire qu'il envisage pour de bon
OK
où il envisagerait pas qu'il s'est 500
[Musique]
c'était survendu ici et ça a été joué
évidemment
on connaît le client
et c'est pas mal j'aime bien que c'est
dur à jouer il est mieux autant en plus
qui met la grosse pression dès la
première partie grosse forme de magnésie
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas le
début de la perte de des carreaux ici
c'est parti
tu vois que il a des gros problèmes
depuis qu'il a
là on aurait changé beaucoup avec les
Blancs
ouais non ouais bien sûr B3 ou V2 était
pas du tout un plan qu'on voit dans ces
structures comme tu l'as dit
et effectivement ça a été pour l'instant
en tout cas les noirs sont mieux et ça a
été pour l'instant c'est puni demain de
mettre par par Magnus Carlson qui va
certainement sur cinq jouer kij4 il a
des coups facile en plus à jouer hein
que j'ai quatre menaces quand même
des cavaliers 3 des tours pendant des
trois cavalief 2 peut-être et garde le
pion C4 au chaud
une surprise pour moi
aussi
comprenne bien tous les deux
et H3 et ce cavalier à plus de 15 je
pense à ça
qu'il joue qualité c'est très rapidement
positionné il a je C4 pour créer ce
cette structure dégueulasse des blancs
et maintenant il va venir manger le pion
dans les bonnes conditions avec le roi
blanc qui est toujours au centre
seul léger bémol
c'est ce fou en H6 qui est quand même
maintenant bien muselé par par cette
structure h2g3 et 4 5 mais il y a
peut-être des G5 qui traînent aussi pour
les Noirs peut-être un jour tout casser
ça peut être aussi une idée
effectivement et pour ces 5 tours C8 est
joué on récupère le pion d'abord
passe ton bac d'abord
c'est encore un coup moche mais
peut-être que c'est la seule solution au
moins on l'a dit oui voilà
quelque chose pour souffrir enfin tu
vois au moins un pion et
voilà tu souffres mettez un pion écoute
il y a des bons cas où les quand les
noirs
ils arrivent plus c'est oublie de créer
de jouer des coups
dynamiques et bien plus mais bon
effectivement c'est pas c'est pas
évident comment on fait ici quand même
c'est pas si il est fort hein
il faut pas il faut pas faire prendre
n'importe quoi quand même tu vois est-ce
que c'est une je sais que ce pion on
veut le gagner peut-être pas les changer
mais je me dis qu'après B6 cavalier
prend j'arrive à faire sur les bonnes
cases genre C4
et que je peux créer des choses et que
si tu prends tu me donnes à faire de fou
et quasiment seront faites m'aider à je
sais pas je suis d'accord c'est un truc
qui s'envisage après il a tellement
toujours pour récupérer ce pion c'est ça
que ça m'étonnerait
mais après tu sais
c'est un jeu d'adaptation donc il faut
quand même parfois faire des choses
qu'on a pas envie de faire
mais je vois plutôt jouer un coup que je
vois pas là mais je comprenait
et
c'est pas un truc fort qui va récupérer
puis on sait 5 et on va dire tu vois en
fait la position laquelle du mal à la
sentir quand tu vois que il y a une
brochette de pièces sous la quand même
là
bravo c'est non mais c'est un coup qui
est assez
enfin tu vois tu vois souvent on va dire
tout ce qui est grandes fêtes tout ça et
ça c'est normal en fait de rendre ce
pion pour ouvrir la ligne
va manquer à l'appel si on le prend et
ça a l'air plus ou moins c'est un
délicate pas prendre parce que le
cavalier peut venir un A4 ou C4 il est
dangereux ou en T5 même parfois pour
venir en C3 bref on a quand même envie
de se débarrasser de ce cavalier mais ça
donne le foot casse noir et
effectivement c'est une concession
alors lui c'est typique il va garder les
pièces et il va il va souffrir
[Musique]
effectivement puis surtout quand il est
en bonne forme et là il a l'air foie F5
et menace à mon avis qui est C4 et comme
ça après on envisage peut-être un
cavalier B2 ou quelque chose comme ça et
donc ça a l'air ça a l'air d'être un
très bon coup ce coup de fouet 5 j'aime
bien peut-être j'ai 5 aussi qui va venir
comme tu l'as dit mais c'est 4 me semble
être une meuf quoi que ça échange des
pièces aussi tu passes complètement sur
mes couilles maintenant
c'est quoi la différence
c'est que le fou c'est que le pion A2
est plus en prise
le pion à deux et plus en prise bon ça
vaut ce que ça vaut mais pourquoi pas il
y a une finesse d'ouvrir la position
attention
c'est assez bizarre c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on a un fond en prison dans sa
position là mais attention
le cavalier en prise j'aimerais bien
venir attaquer manger manger quoi même
s'il y a tout prend tout le temps qui
vient de venir défendre un peu la
baraque
il faut voir concrètement ce qui se
passe
que je peux pas le protéger si
c'est pas évident toujours hein qui est
tellement fort pour poser pour la
pratique en le dira jamais assez il est
là
est-ce que je peux hésité à faire un
fougère échecs tu vois pour te
déstabiliser un peu
ah oui je peux pas faire
déjà et puis après roi c'est un je
voyais pas trop le l'avantage
alors on fait ça
mais encore une fois c'est souvent les
parties du carreaux c'est que ça a l'air
moche mais ça tient un style tout le
temps il est là il est tellement
tellement concret d'ailleurs il y a
toujours été comme ça même quand il
était jeune
rentre en compte au temps à B de weiken
zee un jeune un jeune blitzer et il
était déjà comme ça et je joue archi
concret donc ça ça change pas avec les
années
et ça changera probablement jamais
ça serait marrant de voir les car way
comme style de papi
mais je sais pas si ça va arriver un
jour
et Magnus qui réfléchit qui sent une
fois nous nouvelle fois il est très fort
pour ça c'est un moment critique
manuscrit
s de la graine est-ce qu'on peut pas
replacer ce cavalier qui est ici ce qui
est des 4 je te donne le pion mais au
moins je t'attaque ces deux comment tu
vas le protéger
pas sûr mais
qu'est-ce que je peux pas jouer
parce qu'il va faire de B6
hyper B6 mais regardez la
l'activité des pièces noires c'est quand
même pas mal
placé c'est la seule pièce de noir qui
fait défaut étant C5 à la place ça
serait ah ouais ça serait gagnant juste
après
quand même je m'appelle les flèches mais
c'est c'est trop long
mon impression c'est que les blancs vont
s'en sortir ici
parce que regarde il y a plus de pions
quand même mine de rien je vais rendre
un pion je vais sortir mon truc je vais
faire par exemple je fais fout deux là
tu fais quoi ouais voilà ça y est c'est
jouer tour reprend à deux rois des œufs
pourquoi je vais la perdre cette
position
en vrai
tu t'attends prise
[Musique]
et Tours
quand même très solide alors les Noirs
assez de compensation pour faire nul
mais pas plus à mon avis il a il a raté
son avantage manuscritson
malheureusement
après il est pas non plus mal encore
mais
pour devenir mal il y a un peu moins
faut qu'il fasse très attention
maintenant je peux je peux essayer de
jouer ce plan qu'on avait dit tout à
l'heure avec aussi
certainement faire ça il faut là
j'aurais peut-être Torcé un
de toute façon ouais je pense qu'il va
falloir faire le plan B tu sais quand le
plat ne marche pas on fait le plan B et
essayer de faire ce six fois F8 et
éventuellement certainement prendre en
Détroit et [__] que reposer ça va
faire nul mais nul peu glorieuse alors
que ça avait l'air quand même très très
bien ça avait l'air écrasant bon après
ok sur le papier
par match en deux parties tu finis le
résultat du tout mais quand tu vois la
partie au bout du coup quand même
envie de la gagner quoi OK
maintenant j'ai 5 surtout maintenant ah
il a empêchait des deux G5
donc qu'est-ce qu'il va faire et
carunakamura est-ce qu'il va faire H4 je
pensais H4 ici pour empêcher G5
on fouet
peux pas tout avoir
H4 jouer
j'ai l'impression que ça va revenir au
même au bout du bout il faut essayer
c'est la partie
est-ce que je te colle un échec en B4 tu
fais quoi sur fubéca très chèque
non c'est pas la bonne diago pour le
pour le roi
c'est pour ça que foubecca il n'y a pas
C3 le coup naturel C3 marche pas parce
qu'elle te reprends un deux échec donc
tu es obligé de reculer avec le roi
et pas très agréable mais bon pourquoi
pas surtout prends un deux rois
tu reprendrais
ici je peux revenir en B1 je défends la
tour H1 mais roissy-en-fou C3 par
exemple tu vois le fou il est pas mal
quand même assez
plaisant pour les enfants
même si tu vois la jauge de données
il y a deux plus pour les blancs mais en
fait en pratique c'est dur à descendre
pour la probablement
il y a ces problèmes de pièces le roi
tout ça c'est
après pour ma tour est toujours en B1
qui va qui empêcher les Torah en maths
arrive à s'organiser peut-être un jour
alors c'était la finale hier oui mais
c'est la finale du tableau des gagnants
on rappelle ses doubles élimination donc
là c'est le tableau des pertes entre
guillemets ils ont déjà perdu un match
car on a qu'à moi et manuscrite au
deuxième match perdu ils sont éliminés
le vainqueur défiera demain Fabienne
ucarona et aura la tasse ardu de le
battre deux fois consécutifs dans ces
matchs là mais ardu mais pas impossible
donc on va voir qui sera le grand
vainqueur d'aujourd'hui qui jouera le
grand vainqueur de demain voilà il y a
des vainqueurs des vainqueurs et des
vaincus tous les jours
roi B1 ça me fait peur
il faut trouver un truc là
je crois qu'il va vouloir faire ah non
c'est pas si facile
surtout à huit on va essayer de se
creuser la tête
certainement qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
oui c'est un protège à deux bon ceux qui
est blanc et qui est noir ben en fait
je crois que tout est sur la
présentation en bas la caméra qui est à
côté des blancs et car celle qui est à
côté de noir en plus le temps des blancs
le temps des Noirs dans chaque bulle de
caméra
alors faut prendre les trois c'est
prendre des trois tourbé 3
on va aller manger à deux et
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ah oui ok
je vais pas te laisser manger à deux je
vais faire c'est
non c'est pas ça que je voulais faire je
vais faire à trois mais bon
en prison tu perdais celui-là tu perdais
un peu tout le monde toute la famille et
il rendait cap
pour défendre mais là on est quand même
en foot
il est incroyable
il est incroyable le streamer américain
[Musique]
c'est grave parce que là j'ai pas assez
de compensation peut-être
ah oui joli
la tour ici par découverte alors il y a
eu tour des prends des cadres
c'était mon coup non
oui c'est ton cou
et c'est pas bon mais c'est pas bon
on a vu en fait en bougeant les pièces
donc ça veut dire c'est pas
alors niveau Naka
il l'a vu
en 30 secondes et il va faire tourner
fin et vérifier après mais
c'est bizarre de voir ces deux de
joueurs dans le tableau des perdants
mais bon Fabian a mené son petit
bonhomme de chemin alors place aux
jeunes
Magnus
non il a fait la tête de genre pas genre
ouf incroyable il y a pas vu tous ces
quatre où il y a pas cru il s'est arrêté
à fond
il faut toujours sauver pour les Noirs
mais ça paraît quand même raisonnable
surtout avec les pions les droits comme
tu le disais dès qu'on emprunt on prend
tout le monde donc
je tombais 4 ah oui surtout reprend des
4 il va simplement regarde ça c'est joli
surtout reprendre des cadres il fait
tout reprendre B3 tu reprends AB et fou
prend des 4 et on va se venger sur les
pions le pion de plus je joue pas du
tout c'est même peut-être les noirs qui
sont mieux ici
mais non mais en fait ça va faire nul je
crois que j'ai 4
ans comme ça peut-être
on va redonner un pion et ça a fait la
partie
soit un peu dégoûté attends regarde il
regarde il regarde l'analyse la partie
il va faire le nom de la tête tu vois
il va se taper la tête
de la partie
il vient de voir la gaffe alors la gaffe
on voulait montrer en fait ici donc
c'est un gars que je me suis pris avant
que cartienne se la prenne c'est tout
refait et en fait le fou n'a pas de case
on peut penser qu'il y a tour des deux
avec sur les décors trop fous j'ai tout
reprend à deux et puis il y a des
histoires de perpétuelle par exemple sur
3 bah je fais échec échec échec échec
etc fait nul et si le fou bouge bah je
prends la tour on voit il y a quand même
un problème de de clouage sur ta faute
et là ce que ce que les deux joueurs ont
raté en même temps c'est qu'ici à fou C4
très fort
qui donne la tour mais en fait après
tour prend tour et ben j'ai tout
réchauffe
[Musique]
est très important
si tu joues tomber 8 échec avant C4 ah
non non ça change rien c'est la même
pardon
j'ai une hallucination j'ai cru qu'il
allait tomber de chez
donc ça changera est-ce que j'avais des
petites chances de survie après non
parce que
j'ai tombé trois
ouais d'accord ok donc
tu peux remettre la position après
après fou ces quatre
dans laquelle ou dans l'autre c'est 4G
c'est un bon résultat final pour ma musc
qui aurait pu la perdre et pas loin de
la perdre et alors je vais vous mettre
les caméras pour la pour la rente
d'après
ouais Magnus donc il était très bien
dans le début on l'a dit il mettait la
pression mais
ça crée sacré-caru qui est toujours là
qui se défend comme une bête et qui à la
fin obtient souvent des chances de gains
et ce qui s'est passé il a raté un très
très clair
et bien c'est quand même
c'est quand même dur donc les deux
joueurs ont des raisons d'être
content de cette échappée aussi des
raisons d'être mécontents donc voilà
c'est pas une nul complètement anodine
et de gens ont raté des chances il
rigole il rigole Ikaru Nakamura
et ils sont prêts pour la revanche ou
manus Carlson aura les blancs attention
c'est que deux parties donc s'il y a nul
dans la prochaine on aura le
[Musique]
plaisir de voir un Armageddon avec ce
fameux système dentaire où on rappelle
les blancs en 15 minutes et les Noirs
font des enchères pour savoir s'ils
auront les noirs ou pas là le plus
battant c'est à dire
si on met 9 minutes il va nous faire ça
mais 9 minutes si Nakamura met 8 minutes
et bien c'est Nakamura qui aura 8
minutes à dans le premier tournoi il
s'était passé quelque chose de très
drôle ou Magnus avait mis 8,58 et
ikonakamura avait mis 8,59 donc voilà
c'était Magnus Carson dans la tête du
caroune à moi
assez drôle comme comme fin
de changer la caméra et Magnus qui va
jouer normalement avec les Blancs
il va certainement pas tout miser sur
l'armée Guédon il va essayer de jouer il
est habitué assez assez parti clutch
comme on dit c'est parti décisive non
mais en fait tu vas ouais
deux fois qu'elle me change la caméra
dans ce match donc il y a nul il y a
Stéphane va nous le mettre il y a 0,5 05
donc c'est vraiment le début et on aura
ensuite Maxime Vacher grave très
probablement je sais pas contre qui
contre guéri ou yangi
mais contre un des deux et ensuite ça
sera la fin de la journée mais en tout
cas déjà là on a un très très beau match
entre Carlsen et Nakamura
on aura le nom de celui qui défiera dès
demain Fabian à suivre même endroit même
heure ici
partir de 16 heures très probablement
17 au pire
c'est vrai qu'on est pas au point sur
les sur les horreurs moi je suis pas mis
non on nous a pas trop normalement c'est
16h donc c'est vrai que si Maxime joue
on va la suivre si Maxime joue pas c'est
pas sûr
honnêtement
soyons soyons très honnête donc voilà on
vous annoncera ça évidemment en fin de
en fin de stream
mais on espère que Maxime se refasse
dans le match
contre guéri ou
la Magnus qui a décalé sa caméra
qui font que de sauter ça c'est le
voilà il y a un souci caméra c'est le
zoom qui me saute
d'accord ça devrait être bon
de demander des nouvelles alors je vais
voir si on a des nouvelles par rapport à
guéri et ce qui se passait
alors 70-86
c'est ce que dit Laurent
je sais pas
ok un MVV qui va commencer dans quelques
instants
alors c'est cassé une gagne enfin bon si
d'ailleurs Nakamura ainsi on ira voir
cette partie de mvl contre guéri
évidemment
et il joue une avec fou D2 bon quelque
chose de très modeste mais attention ça
a quand même du venin c'est très à la
mode ces derniers temps et on voit qu'on
a qu'à moi qui commence à réfléchir
mais voilà on veut tout simplement jouer
le petit coup à deux à trois les blancs
vont prendre ces trois et on va
reprendre du Fou
c'est ça l'idée c'est aussi simple que
ça on va manger le ou en fait
gratuitement
la structure
il y a le 4 on rend le fou
mais on a l'avantage d'espace quand même
et un peu de développement bon alors
effectivement les noix ont des solutions
c'est vraiment quelque chose pour jouer
aux échecs et pas forcément pour gagner
dans l'ouverture
mais voilà maintenant dans son style ça
correspond très bien à son style ce
genre de choses
voir ce que va faire de la caille il
faut penser à comment est-ce qu'on sort
les dames est-ce qu'on conteste le
centre par des 7 dessins ou des 7 des 6
est-ce qu'on fait une attaque par la
Mach 4 je sais pas mais B6 c'est
intéressant
qui va pas trop trop je vois un truc qui
connaît pas trop non
ouais d'accord mais il a joué une autre
Nimzo contre les von Aronian juste avant
donc
quand même il faut réviser avant les
parties tu vois c'est pas c'est pas
donné qui soit dans tous les moindres
détails de chaque variante mais là il a
l'air de d'être bien dans les détails
celle-là et tout 8 il n'a qu'à moi qui a
l'air aussi de croissant
et voilà Magnus a l'air d'être au top
book alors comment on fait ici
est-ce qu'on fait F3 est-ce qu'on fait
G3
j'en sais rien
je voudrais plutôt G3 au feeling pour
faire fouger 2
et ce développer gentiment
F3 est possible aussi avec
en force le cavalier à s'échanger sur le
fou en C3
et
on reprend du cavalier en ce moment là
le Fou est fin pourrait se développer de
manière plus naturelle en Détroit
quelque chose comme ça
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
j'ai trois
moi je suis plutôt concret
alors F3 vas-y regarde non F3 je prends
C3 tu prends je prends un dessin
du coup non là tu as perdu trois
tu m'as donné la
tu peux prendre de la dame aussi
peut-être de la dame c'est joli parce
que si tu prends la dame tu reprends le
3 il y a roi roi bouge roi F2 attaque la
tour elle s'attaque les deux tours
[Musique]
mais F30 tu vois c'est pour ça me semble
pas si évident si tu prends du cavalier
en dessin je vais faire fout baisse
et ensuite je vais attaquer le cavalier
en dessin qui est appuyant le 3 derrière
[Musique]
je pense que c'est ça celle là ok moi je
regardais celle-là aussi je veux rendre
mais
non d'abord tout va vite et ensuite ok
d'accord oui d'ailleurs je crois que
j'ai compris pourquoi c'est nul c'est
perpète j'ai trois dames des 4
d'ailleurs c'est joli projet 2 Dame des
deux et sur wash 3D 3
c'est
ok intéressant
ouais j'ai trois fougères
et regardons un beau vis-à-vis avec
cette tour en 8 qui traîne donc moi je
suis team team G3 Magnus qui prend son
temps il essaie de voir
d'évaluer les les différentes options
il a bien raison enfin en tout cas il
faut pas non plus toujours pareil
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué Magnus il a fait
sourire icarbonakamura
[Musique]
à la fin
ça peut être ça
en tout cas 3 minutes pour jouer à 4
Magnus
donc bon il connaît pas et il est
créatif
toujours H4 c'est quand même c'est pas
un coup que tu peux sortir comme ça
en pote image 4 mais bon ok c'est on est
en 2023 qu'est-ce que tu veux
l'intelligence artificielle a fait son
œuvre Lila qui propose H4 maintenant
dans le top 3 des Lilas il y a souvent
H4
et donc c'est vrai que Magnus a été un
des premiers à utiliser ce ces choses là
jusqu'à 4h5 H6 et puis après la tour qui
joue mais il joue puis on prend des
seins qui jouent au centre et car on a
qu'à moi
et maintenant comment on fait il va
falloir faire grand rock on peut pas le
faire tout de suite quand parce qu'il
prend F2 donc la fourchette en F2 on
voit ce pion faible mais
on peut le
préparer comment vas-y puisque tu aimes
bien 4 vas-y propose-moi un coup
quelques arrives à 30 ans
que le cavalier reste là parce que si tu
veux mon cavalier
quoi
c'est déjà dans les problèmes ah non pas
j'ai trois maintenant c'était avant
j'étais plus
faire G3 là il y a plus de à mon avis il
y a plus de voix
contre aronia maintenant
[Musique]
est-ce qu'il aurait fait un pari avant
avant cette journée Magnus aujourd'hui
[Musique]
tu vois en fait après je pense que c'est
parce que j'ai un peu mûri aussi
à l'époque j'étais le mec qui rentrait
jamais fait n'importe comment maintenant
je suis un peu attention quand même
j'aime bien avoir en sécurité
ouais voilà je veux je veux avoir mon
sécurité et après je pourrais attaquer
tranquillement sans me prendre la tête
[Rires]
donc H5 pour faire H6 bon le coût
automatique ici avec les Noirs c'est H7
H6 bon VH4 c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'a
dit un jour quand on joue quand on se
dit ah quand on joue à 4 normalement
c'est pour jouer H5 donc c'est logique
c'est vrai qu'avec les noirs on a quand
même le court réflexe à cet H6 on n'a
pas envie de laisser H6 parce qu'après
il y aura un réseau de maths autour de
Rouen
paralyse un peu la position blanche tu
vois qu'il empêche le cavalier de bouger
parce que sinon j'aurais cabane pour
cette 3 avec un structure qui serait
démolie et j'ai du mal vraiment à bouger
à cause de ça il y a aussi même du
cavalier.f.2 qu'on peut peut-être
envisager de temps en temps avec on va
prendre un
f2f4 on peut le montrer qui avait F4 par
exemple qui est pris F2 et là c'est
ouais donc c'est vrai que le cavalier en
quatre il est assez fort et
c'est la meilleure pièce de noir ici
c'est très bien joué
c'est évident normal
complètement normal et maintenant
et maintenant monsieur
Carlson que fait-on
mais en fait je suis positionné normal
tu veux faire où j'ai 4 je sais pas
[Musique]
du coup assise
un jour ça m'a l'air un peu mou je pense
qu'il faut rester comme ça
là il faut aller il faut un truc plus
rapide
et donc ça bouge pas lui il a pas de
case ça a du mal à jouer faites par
élimination
tu as envie de te dire que tu auras
trois c'est un coup mais après un coup
de style
je sais pas
et moi je passe mon tour fais quoi
en fait j'ai une idée concrète la B3 fou
B2
force un petit peu à me prendre le fou
ce qui m'arrange parce que comme ça m'en
fous de casse blanche il pourra sortir
et si tu me le prends pas je fais tous
mes deux je garde mon fou et il a joué
Dame des trois là
et ouais non moi ça m'avait l'air
bizarre parce que l'impression que j'ai
peut-être le temps de faire quelque
chose et j'aime bien ton goût facile
je les vois
non mais après il y a le pire oui j'ai
vu mais bon oui oui je suis d'accord je
te le donne mais après peut-être que
c'est pas bien en fait il faut défendre
un peu avant de faire fois 6
alors Jean-Louis Aubert le problème
c'est que ton H4 la tour était en prise
ça c'est une question on fera ça à la
pose ceinture galmiral et les questions
qui peuvent durer longtemps pourquoi toi
et en plus
c'est une question j'ai pas vraiment la
réponse
tant que je peux te raconter tout ce que
j'ai envie de te raconter mais tu sais
j'ai pas eu de d'explication j'ai pas eu
un mail avec les explications j'ai
choisi pour cette raison cette raison
cette raison c'est que de colonne des
positif et de négatif tu sais j'ai plus
ça j'ai juste eu une proposition de
travailler voilà
moi je peux faire des suppositions tu
peux en faire
j'ai peut-être plus d'infos
effectivement mais j'ai pas de réponse
claire voilà
une fois en partie longue et deux trois
fois en [__]
sinon il va pas te oui c'est ça
j'imagine que pour que pour pour
travailler avec Magnus ça va ce rôle de
second nom comme comme tu l'as déjà bah
il faut il faut être très bon rapport
avec avec Mamie parce que sinon bah ça
se passe pas bien aussi pour savoir si
le travail il y a des chèques et
chercher des variantes analyser etc et
donc ça c'est comme qualité qui a dû
voir quand tu es parti sûrement tu sais
il y a que des catins j'ai failli caca
excuse-moi donc je te parlais j'ai pensé
à ça pour mater comme ça pendant que je
te parlais et
en français
c'est-à-dire que la relation travaille
la relation personnelle évidemment qui
est donc il a dû me trouver sympa et
puis après ça on a tout de suite
accroché et puis voilà oui et puis il a
dû voir aussi que quand tu es parti tu
as un joueur qui travaille correctement
qui qui a un bon répertoire et qui fait
en fait
il va reprendre un charlot quoi
tu es sérieux quoi quand
en plus honnêtement j'ai un peu tu vois
en fait les coups les cookies jouent
enfin tu vois on a peur on a un peu le
même style il a évidemment le même style
en plus fort mais j'ai un peu le même
style tu vois donc ça aide aussi tu vois
pour comprendre aussi ce qui va bien
aimer comme variante tu vois en fait
j'aime bien
goûts
que ton coton patron bah du coup on
prend ce qui va aimer ce qui va pas
aimer quoi ouais tu vas pas lui proposer
n'importe quoi
voilà moi non plus j'aime pas
clairement donc il y a ça aussi il y a
une question de d'affinité de style de
voilà le travail comme tu l'as dit la
relation personnelle c'est très
important pour lui il a ce côté très
famille on voit son perte voyage
toujours avec lui donc côté très famille
ou c'est important pour lui qui a une
sorte de clan entre guillemets dans le
sens positif du terme le côté travail
sérieux et le côté style aussi qui
correspondait donc
[Musique]
voilà je pense que c'était
c'est principalement principalement la
raison mais je sais pas il m'a jamais
dit non pourquoi non non il m'a toujours
dit que il était très content du travail
voilà et c'est quelqu'un qui est très
agréable parce que je vais le redire
mais je j'en suis fait 10 ans que je
travaille pour lui et donc c'est
quelqu'un qui dit jamais plein de
manières publiques ni de manière privée
et pourtant
je suppose qu'il y a des moments où il
était pas soit pas très content de ce
qu'on de notre rendu soit
il aurait préféré que ça soit je sais
pas enfin tu vois le travail est pas
toujours à 2000% quoi donc c'est normal
et il ne s'est jamais plaint toujours
été très reconnaissant et donc donc très
agréable de travailler avec manuscrit
alors qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de ce
sacrifice de qualité qui est mieux
pourquoi
vous avez vu Magnus évidemment ce cahier
des quatre mais il y a une petite
séquence tempo
très impressionnante les deux joueurs
qui sont sur une autre planète comme
toujours
[Musique]
ça attaque la dame ici parce qu'il y a
plus la défense de la tour sur la dame
et ça menace maths en CD donc tout
reprenez 4 est obligatoire je prends ici
la dame était changée et on prend ça
urger la position s'ouvre donc il vaut
mieux échanger les dames parce que le
roi et on fait cavalier F4 et c'est
qu'on a la paire de fou et deux pions en
compensation alors ce Cavalaire le 4 est
toujours un monstre comme tu l'avais dit
quand tu as dit Stéphane
c'est une position très très complexe
très dur à jouer pour les deux camps
est-ce que un coup de B5 peut être
intéressant c'est pas idiot B6 B5 une
petite rupture tant que les blancs sont
pas développés
comment on freine les blancs peut-être
P3
et
pourtant 56 je vais pas en deux mots en
un mot et rejoindre Gustave Sand pour
second degré
voilà tout ce qu'il a jamais ça
n'arrivera jamais ça c'est des trucs
alors ça c'est jamais voilà
c'est simple jamais
mais voilà et j'avais l'expert oui dans
c'est ça oui parce qu'il parle de cramé
parce que j'ai travaillé pour cramer
qu'en 2008 pour 120 donc j'avais une
certaine expérience aussi de ces de ces
malchanteurs du monde et du travail avec
des Forgeois enfin des forts
c'est plus qu'un Forgeur c'est un ancien
champion du monde
aussi ça qui a certainement jouer dans
le dans la la proposition de de Magnus
de travailler pour lui
et la chance aussi alors cahier
s'attaque le pion C4
pour moi
B3 pour les deux du coup
pour moi tu sais je crois qu'il sans lui
je les aurais pas gagné moi tous ces
balles champion du monde
tandis que sans moi il serait peut-être
débrouillé
un champion du monde un champion il y en
a un seul il y a 2 secondes il peut y en
avoir beaucoup beaucoup
il a plus
je vois que c'est grand monde donc
c'est quoi ta ligne cavalier F5
ah je pensais qu'il y a 5 mois
et là il y a un problème sur D4 et
attention tu fais tu bouges le fou ah
oui un enfant
deux je fais je prends des quatre et je
fais tout 4 je pense sont les grosses
différences entre le travail avec Marius
toute la journée et
hyper à la fin non cramique est très dur
avec lui-même et avec les autres et donc
c'est mais en gros ça change pas grand
chose
mais non non en fait
il travaille beaucoup lui-même et
[Musique]
et
très exigeant et son grand kiffe à
cramique c'est tu dors pas la nuit je
pense que cramique est un mauvais leader
par rapport à Magnus qui est un
excellent leader voilà
je pense que cramique c'était son
grand kiffe à cramique c'est une nuit
pour que tu travailles les variantes
mais le problème c'est qu'après une
semaine tu es crevé un peu plus et tu
fais du bruit de travail
dans le truc de confort des
secondes et donc je pense que c'est un
meilleur chef de j'avais vu d'ailleurs
que vous étiez parti à notre bout du
monde
il y avait peu de monde qui était un peu
de personnes qui étaient avec lui lors
du monde
Nielsen mais il y avait il y a toute une
équipe mais qui était qui était parti à
l'autre bout du monde avec un décalage
horaire différent pourquoi pas être pour
pas être lésé par travailler la nuit
quoi
exactement
le truc et en fait tu prends du plaisir
à le faire simplement
travailler ce qui est aussi sympa aussi
niveau boulot
Gustave sonne et Jordan van forest donc
on était tous les quatre en Thaïlande
donc c'était il y a pire qu'on a droit
quand même et cramé qui vivait à Paris
donc voilà ça c'est fait naturellement
on était en gros les deux plus fort
joueurs qui étaient Paris
un adulte voilà
donc c'est un petit moment
et
Magnus qui a des chances et 4 ah là là
là il souffre le numéro mondial
manuscrite
de l'élimination là pour Magnus alors ça
reste quand même solide cette structure
avec ce fond en D4 qui tient un peu tout
de moi donc clairement
c'est pas encore fait mais là c'est dur
en plus il a peu de temps la pendule je
vous rappelle qu'il y a quand même trois
secondes par coup c'est 15 + 3 la
cadence à 4 à 4 ça prépare clairement
tour à un pour jouer à 5 et pour essayer
plus en échange de pions mieux on se
porte avec les Blancs Magnus qui va
essayer de sauver alors il est très fort
c'est comme kasparoff et c'était
champion du monde qui sont très forts
pour pour sauver des positions
inférieures et d'ailleurs Magnus a quand
même eu cette ce record d'investibilité
je crois 125 parties
il en a eu des perdantes dedans vous en
doutez bien et même des super perdantes
et donc voilà il a ce côté
où il pose toujours la dernière question
où il se bat comme il carou d'ailleurs
c'est la marque des très grands
champions et donc Magnus a eu ce recours
d'invessibilité aussi grâce à ça
je sais plus comment c'est d'ailleurs
125 comme ça c'est une centaine il a été
et je crois qu'il a perdu le contrôle
Douda il a perdu
mais il devait en perdre avant il a été
raide c'était je me rappelle au grand
Suisse à l'île de manne à deux trois
parties étaient à moins 10 mais moins 10
vraiment complètement cuit et puissance
il est là quoi il te fait jouer le coup
de plus le coup de plus le coup de plus
et puis finalement il est plus foutu
ça c'est à ce niveau là c'était ouf en
plus quand on est joueur parce qu'il
joue pas contre contre des joueurs qui
sont
contre le top 10 tout le temps quoi en
fait et là quand tu joues 125 parties
contre le top 10 et ton père pas une bah
c'est chaud quoi
parce que moi je le 125 je remplace 25
non j'avais le contre
[Musique]
c'était un truc de fou j'avais pris je
crois le premier jour c'était il y a
quelques années il m'avait mis un truc
du style 30-0
il m'a défié il m'a défié j'ai accepté
un micro-ondes zéro et le lendemain
il m'a redéfié j'ai [__] il a encore
quoi et je dis bon bah j'accepte en plus
le premier jour c'est une journée où
j'avais eu beaucoup beaucoup de courses
et je travaille à Cannes et c'était le
mercredi le mercredi j'avais ma journée
où j'enchaînais vraiment mais bon c'est
pas une excuse mais voilà et
bon
[Musique]
demain je le rejoue et il me remet
environ 15-0 quoi
et comment
t'as jamais fait une nul et non mais on
a continué et là j'ai j'en ai gagné une
je fais une nul juste derrière et après
[__] j'en ai regagné une encore fait
et bon bah j'ai perdu là ça tourne là
peut-être 30 à 3 quoi de nulle de
victoire un truc comme ça et à la fin la
dernière partie je prends la nuit avec
le tour de moi
parce que j'en pouvais plus l'arrêter le
match en fait ok stop arrête et quand je
l'ai battu il m'a fait un petit
commentaire à bien sympa dans le chat
comme quoi j'étais nul quoi
c'est pas moi qui
streamer comme quoi j'étais nul bon il
faisait souvent
et sinon l'autre fois j'ai une histoire
mais je pense qu'on a qu'à le saura
jamais mais il streamait et en fait je
suis dans mon lit et donc je me réveille
un matin voilà l'ordinateur portable sur
les genoux au fond de mon lit et là je
lance bon bah un peu Facebook un peu
télescope
au fond de mon lit et j'étais à Mister
en plus bah j'excelle par pi j'ai ouvert
son stream je jouais je jouais avec le
touchpad au fond de mon lit et je l'ai
battu je l'ai maté comme un chien et il
a pas su que j'étais au pad allongé dans
mon lit tu vois
après la partie il a coupé le stream
c'était c'était la partie
et voilà bon du coup je lui passe pour
trois fois dans ma vie
mais j'ai une soixantaine de défaites
mais après c'est pas c'est pas honteux
parce que tu es nul ouf il a proposé nul
d'accord ok il commençait à faire la mou
il a proposé ça paraît dur il y a pas de
faiblesse hein côté blanc regardez tous
les pions sont protégés par les pièces
les pièces sont indénibles fous des
quatre cavaliers F4 donc c'est très dur
de percer en fait il est un peu il a
laissé faire ce à quatre à cinq et quand
même on peut le remontrer peut-être
Stéphane parce que ce à quatre était
quand même diabolique c'est une belle
idée parce que ça ça
rend le fou à cette beaucoup plus fort
enfin le foie ça te fous des quatre sur
diagonale les pions sont faibles les
pièces s'activent chez les Blancs à
Tours et est-ce qu'il y a moyen
d'empêcher d'empêcher à 5
peut-être pas
évident ça c'est vrai qu'en fait
il a rien fait d'un car il a fait
tourner ton dessin attendu
scruter mon Twitter pour essayer d'avoir
les infos sur le sur la cadence on va
rigoler encore
mais là on va avoir des des enchères
très basses clairement je pense
on a ça va être aux alentours de ça sera
moins de 10 minutes c'est sûr on aura du
du aux alentours de 9 comme d'hab
ils se sont mis d'accord il y a une
sorte de consensus autour de ces 9
minutes donc moi je les vois mettre du 9
minutes
parce que entre ces deux joueurs quand
même s'ajouterait vite ça peut jouer
très vite donc le l'avantage de pouvoir
faire nul et quand même énorme et donc
ils veulent vraiment une grosse
compensation
ne vous inquiétez pas oui moi j'ai battu
en
rapide bonnes parties avec d'accord il
m'a battu il apparaît sans son stream il
a battu une fois en partie longue bon
bref mais en 2004 justement la partie
dont je parlais on a joué plusieurs
parties longues je sais pas il y a eu
des nuls et j'ai perdu mais je l'ai
battu une fois rapide au mind games pour
ceux qui a une chose
ça a bien marché et
il y aura l'air après la partie
je peux faire ouais mais bon il joue
tellement il pousse tellement en fait tu
lui répètes les coups et tu sais qu'il
va changer donc en fait même si tu es
mieux tu répètes les coups
tu vois
ben ouais je sais pas il se plaint après
les coups et puis on fait nul et puis
c'est tout
alors on va avoir ce
fameux Armageddon avec les enchères
ça va être beau quand c'est que
il est en train de jouer là je peux vous
mettre la partie Dembélé
après je pense qu'on a mal au dos je
peux pas changer
[Musique]
alors Maxime avec les Blancs contre un
nidge surtout qu'il y a honnêtement il a
un petit format aujourd'hui
je peux avoir les résultats
des bêtes un des
dans les résultats
je peux avoir les
ce qui propose niveau Paris pour la
magazine
d'accord mais je vais la voir bientôt
sur mon sur mon twitter mais bon tu l'as
dans le zoom non non non non mais
apparemment
apparemment je voulais avoir enfin je
peux avoir sur
[Musique]
ils sont mis apparemment je sais pas
on va voir en tout cas cette partie
entre Maxime achaggrave et qui c'est ce
que j'allais dire entre Maxime Vacher et
qui se dirige vers une nul donc il y
aura la revanche et ensuite
peut-être Armageddon
peut-être le nécessaire à marguerdon ça
recommence direct
en veux-tu en voilà c'est la nouvelle
arme de de mvl qui lui aurait
c'est pas mal qu'il a ajouté un truc à
sa grande Feld
et c'est Camille
va jouer la petite finale ou pas où
est-ce qu'il va tenter sa chance dans
une variante plus principale B3 et très
à la mode
puis on prend ses 5 et toujours toujours
quelque chose sur lequel il faut compter
après il y a énormément de coups dans
cette position il y a tout 4 qui est C3
kbd2 ma mère coûterait à 4 et aussi une
possibilité
énormément en fait
pardon tout ce jour en fait tout se joue
quasiment tous les coups se jouent
car les mining Games 2012 bien sûr qu'on
connaît
le droit de ta vie c'est ça Laurent
mais bon il y a beaucoup de gens qui
demandent ce que c'est alors oui c'est
le
résultat ever de l'eau
en tournoi il a il enchaîné tout le
temps
une pièce avec une box
c'est vrai
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a joué dis-donc il
s'est passé E4 B5 fois 2 qui prend le 4
ça crée
donc ce 4 et une ligne théorique
et après on joue on joue les
compensations on joue l'avantage de
développement c'est évidemment très
intéressant
mais bon c'est toujours ça coûte un pion
qui est BD on a davantage évidemment de
développement on peut pas prendre 4 et
je vais quitter j'ai 5 là c'est ça
9 17 pour hikao et 9 27 pour Magnus
donc Hikaru elle est noir
27 ok il l'a eu cette fois
il l'a eu cette fois il l'a eu à 10
secondes près c'est normal je vais
remettre du coup la caméra des joueurs
parce que je pense que là il doit mettre
en forme de tête
bon je vous laisse la partie mvl pour
l'instant
c'était caméra de de Magnus et de Naka
pour voir un peu de ce qu'ils arrivent
et on voit Maxime donc qui joue très
très vite dans cette position
donc ça c'est la ça c'est la
première
finale dépend
à la première finale des de la course
Hollande des perles
et le gagnant de de cette partie enfin
de ce match là
contre abdos
allez Maxime
tu gagnes au mieux un pion là la jauge
elle monte vraiment un gros avantage
noir
tout à fait
est-ce que Maxime il sait pas qu'il y a
un truc mais c'est ça c'est un tel
avantage de savoir qu'il y a un truc
mais il faut que je cours en fait parce
que parce que la jauge quand même
Maxime qui risque de gagner
mais il faut qu'il voit c'est pas très
dur non
pour un tacticien du calibre de Maxime
ça paraît quand même chose
très très possible
et voilà
demain il va il va frotter à Bruxelles
pour la deuxième fois
elle sera pour la finale cette fois-ci
la finale
deux fois
là il gagne une pièce
tout simplement
qui a peut-être eu un souvenir il
souvenait il croyait se souvenir mais en
fait il s'est trompé je vais voir si
j'ai ça caméra
l'emporter
donc je suis prêt à ouvrir son ex ça
commence en plus guéri c'est pas le
genre à se battre
à se battre ah bah continuez avec une
pièce de moi
alors à Magnus a commencé à mon avis
ça y est il y a qui lève les yeux au
ciel
on va pas rater une miette évidemment de
cet armage et donc qui définira le lui
qui va challenger Fabian qui est pour
l'instant est très dominateur dans ce
chassable Masters
[Musique]
et c'est Carlson qui a les blancs dans
cette partie donc c'est 15 minutes
contre 8,40 quand même non
beaucoup de temps
une petite anglaise logique on veut une
partie
longueur longtemps
et tout va vite petit rock et de
connaître son histoire manus Carlson
et on voit les carreaux qui a déjà
réfléchi une minute qui descend et c'est
pas mal ça pour les blancs moi j'aime
bien
ce qui est ce coup de cahier des 5
qui doit déjà résoudre des problèmes un
petit peu pas très agréable
et attention
attention parce que c'est quand même les
six minutes peuvent
parler je crois qu'on est obligé de
prendre des cinq parce que si tu joues
un coup de fou genre kb5 ça peut faire
très très mal j'ai l'impression que je
masquer quand même
être obligé de prendre des 5 mais dans
des masques conditions j'ai des 600
suites qui arrivent c'est vraiment pas
l'air terrible
donc à mon avis il faut prendre des deux
cavaliers
il a mangé là on mange du pion
et qui prend des crêpes important le
petit tempo sur le fousset 5 et dame 7
protège le fou
[Musique]
je peux pas faire faux 3 ici pour
empêcher justement ton coup-fou C5 et
pour empêcher des 7 D6 et comment tu
fais pour pour t'organiser là il y
aurait le fou en prise c'est pas mal
j'ai une thématique des cinq décises et
je donne un pion pour te faire
ah oui
je vais faire tourner en plus avec tempo
donc là mon avis il faut bouger la dame
pour essayer d'en empêcher pas évident
il y a pas de promu en fait dans les
divisions de saint-amensonge de notre
ami
Laurent donc non
je parle incompétence voilà
c'est juste c'est pas c'est pas fait
exprès quoi c'est pas un mensonge pour
le plaisir c'est vraiment c'est de
l'incompétence c'est tout non mais ça
paraissait logique en fait au final
je te remercie non mais c'est vrai
le premier pourrait mériter ça quand
même mais bon franchement
oui oui
B6 ok il faut bien sortir ce fou on peut
faire à 7 à 5 ensuite et jouer x 6 parce
que le fond en V7 toute façon il est pas
terrible donc on va plutôt essayer de
sortir vers racisme fou et peut-être
éventuellement comme tu le montres fous
c'est ça
alors peut-être que si tu veux empêcher
footer 5 et un coup de Dame des deux
peut-être pas si bête pour essayer
d'avoir des six à chaque fois
tu vois
j'ai ça ouais
prévention comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure après je sais pas ce que je dois
leur Détroit où en D2 parce que
en Détroit à cinq fois six donc il y a
du poids du compte mais là on peut on
peut répéter longtemps attends mais je
peux faire des six non
je crois que du matériel
je prends là je prends là tu as tout en
l'air ok tu as raison tu as raison ça je
coupe tout j'attaque tout tout tout tes
pièces là
tu prends des deux je prends je prends
le
donc ça pas donc même des deux est un
bon coup
à 6 parce que faut enlever ça de toute
façon l'avoir en C8 ou en baisser ça
change pas grand chose ça risque quand
même il tape sur le pion 2 et ça crée du
vrai vrai contre jeux pour les Noirs
évidemment les Blancs ont l'air mieux
parce que il y a plus en C7 qui est
faible mais ça reste quand même
[Musique]
loin pour les Noirs tout simplement
après je sais pas ce que tu en penses
mais il me semble que l'ouverture est
quand même plutôt en faveur de de Magnus
surtout que il a gardé son avantage
autant six minutes d'avance ils sont
tout à fait jouable légère avantage bon
ben c'est exactement ce qu'on veut dans
une partie armage et donc quand on a un
aussi net avantage de autant je suis
tombé 8 ça c'est étonnant comme coup
est-ce que les joueurs
ils peuvent se voir dans le zoom je
pense mais est-ce qu'ils ont le droit
d'avoir
l'écran zoom ouvert pour voir ton
adversaire je crois que tu as le droit
tu as juste parce que tu partages ton
écran
donc tant que l'arbitre voit ce que tu
vois
je crois je sais pas moi je suis jamais
allé quand j'ai joué
même pas chercher à aller chercher je
sentais que j'allais tout faire casser
donc j'ai même pas cherché à avoir
j'avais la réponse sous mes yeux mais en
fait bah j'ai pas cherché à j'ai trop
peur que ça casse parce qu'après c'est
bien de pouvoir des fois voir qu'on
adversaire pendant quelques jours ça
donne comme des impôts ça rassure ou pas
et c'est vrai que des fois c'est quand
tu joues aux échecs 80% à chaque fois
et je sais pas si regarde la combinette
de manuscrit
je pense qu'il se voit
possible en tout cas je pense que Maggie
se voit d'accord qu'il a son petit
regard à droite ma glisse c'est que
je pense que on va le montrer ce qui est
sûr de prendre un deux c'était assez
joli et encore un truc thématique on a
montré sur cette faiblesse de la tour
pas protégée tourin et dame prend des
deux en fait tout reprend à 8 échec
intermédiaire voilà
donc c'est pour ça qu'il joue fois 6 si
car on a qu'à moi mais on élimine ce fou
en descis alors tôt ou tard je sais pas
exactement quand mais voilà ce sont des
sites va être échangé ce pur en C7 va
être une faiblesse
chronique et Magnus Carson qui mène très
très bien ça ça barque dans cette partie
avec un avantage et toujours ce temps
qui fait défaut à Ikaru Nakamura qui
réfléchit après 4 toujours les 6 minutes
d'avance qui sont présentes
[Musique]
je vais doubler sur la colonne
il y a eu la partie c'est ça
la partie
bah ouais je pensais pas je j'essayais
un truc en pensant que non ça va pas
pour les Noirs en fait c'est la partie
donc voyez il a joué dame D8 pour
l'espace et la tour en recettes parce
que ça allait bien que pour défendre le
pion ici j'ai du mal à mettre cette
pièce là comme ça
donc dame D8 tactos recette H4 pour
mettre le fond facilement et je les
garde ah j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
ce qu'il fait là avec un tour en C3 qui
permet de doubler mais qui en plus
permet de garder un oeil sur la
troisième rangée
mimiques mais ouais effectivement il
joue sur les deux ailes il a bien raison
ou F6 que ça fait pas plaisir de jouer
comme ça peut-être faut acheter
cinq invasions aussi on peut jamais
faire foudre si elle pure C7 en l'air
c'est un cauchemar pour ikonakamura il a
une poubelle
assez incroyable on peut même peut-être
envisager G5 direct c'est pas si mal
aussi
il veut faire sur G5 j'ai compris ce
qu'il voulait faire il veut faire pion
prend mais même ça en fait FG HG et
Tours F7
mais oui non ça c'est pas clair non non
ça il faut le préparer OK
il y a quand même sur la carte de 6 même
si au final
je crois ou tout repenser cette lettre
mais je pensais plus en prendre plutôt
c'est chaud pour les pour les noirs
il est cuit
[Musique]
en plus toujours bon plus que 5 minutes
d'avance mais ça reste quand même très
très raisonnable c'est du chaos et une
belle position pour pour
matériel mais le roi noir vous voyez il
est quand même très très faible parce
que j'ai échec là même pas où je dois
aller manger 6 ou en G8 mais
[Musique]
c'est pas un chargeur
la situation je critique mais enfin je
critique je critique pas je le dis que
c'est la position et délicate puisque
délicate c'est tellement dur en fait ce
que tu dois jouer avec vous
sur sur projet si j'ai peut-être 5h je
pense
[Musique]
Magnus archi concentré
c'est la fin du tournoi pour un des deux
pour un de géant
c'est la fin du tournoi dans maximum de
12 minutes donc restez parce que là
c'est le moment vraiment guéri Guiri sur
le cul selon GG ah bah oui mais ça moi
j'espérais déjà qui l'ai perdu
je peux pas voir la partie
malheureusement
moi je vois un zéro je sais pas si c'est
la partie qu'on a vu tout à l'heure
pour pour la finale contre
demain donc je crois que c'est encore à
16h on aura
vérifier mais normalement
possible
alors ouais possible on sait pas on sait
pas on sait pas disons là c'est c'est
juste un petit coup ton tour et ouais
effectivement la tendance du coup était
bonne pour les
ça c'est sûr
c'est chiant ce tour tu peux dire bon je
fais ça je temporise un peu j'essaie de
faire un truc
je pense que même ça il y a
échec voilà
je sais pas du tout ce que je voudrais
et pourtant conscient de la belle
position
parce que la finale on peut tenter la
finale de dame mais non
pour ces 7 3 8 tours C8 échec roi monte
et je t'échange je t'ai changé tout
c'est une meilleure structure mais ça va
pas suffire
est-ce qu'il va aller pour ça
parce que là
et
[Musique]
peut-être que je peux manger par dame
j'ai trois mais bon
je pense qu'il a pas le choix
actif avec
cette dame en M6 qui tape sur B2 et il
va faire damashe8 un truc comme ça
[Musique]
je sais pas où il va peut-être
ici et ça c'est la dame noire s'en va
j'ai ça et je crois que c'était sur
échec il y a des F4 là des trucs comme
ça c'est pénible
objectivement nul c'est sûr alors le
temps et non le temps il est revenu
autant qu'est-ce qu'il est fort
[Musique]
même j'ai 4 pas mal
il faut le prendre en plus
attention si tu me laisses un temps roi
G6 ok mais je fais ranger deux
et peut-être F3 et tu vas ranger
en défenseur quoi
là
partout à part G8 et 8
peut-être en G8 c'est mieux Corsa ça ça
attention attention j'ai dame début de
me prendre les cinq aussi qui se
regardent mais dans 6 c'est ce que je me
prends un perpète ou pas c'est ça ma
grande question mais je crois pas il
Adam G3 simplement
[Musique]
un peu mon pion et sur dame E4 chez roi
G3 mais c'est le chèque possible c'est
ici et là je m'enfuis
parce que là
son temps aussi la nuit d'avance quand
même pour ces quand même énorme c'est
quand même beaucoup c'est lui qui vous
rappelle
on peut pas vous donner la dame noire
parce que
[Musique]
je pense
et voir place
il y a des plans droits B5 aussi alors
attendez
est-ce que dame F4 est possible sur roi
des trois c'est ça la grande question
bon on reste on reste on va pas analyser
on reste sur le direct parce que
ça va jouer hors du mal à suivre là
c'est le ça c'est les peut-être les cinq
les cinq minutes décisives du tournoi
je suis d'accord
mais ça te pose des questions en tout
cas pour moi c'est un coup qui a mêlant
la position peut-être avec du dame BK
même six que 20 secondes d'avance pour
manuscrite
au diable bon c'est pas fini mais c'est
quand même petite petite avantage Naka
là
avec cette nul évidemment qui lui donne
la victoire
dame Descartes
là que je me demandais est-ce que c'est
nul ou pas
[Musique]
j'arrête les échecs
pour le moment en tout cas pour manger
là mais bon là j'ai un peu c'est quand
même qui est assez fort
il faut que je mette madame sur la
grande diagonale c'est chaud je vais
tout de suite
ok c'est la partie incroyable il a une
minute d'avance Magnus cars scène
attention Naka alors c'est champion de
Bullet mais quand même ah il empêche
il empêche la meinque
[Musique]
c'est chaud
bonsoir
incroyable
de dernière minute de ce match a le
temps
dans une 50 on sait hein
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça 45 secondes
je suis pas sûr
quand même
et il a cru qu'il avait pas lâché il a
joué dans le jeu de la machine
tu vois tu vas pour jouer le coup en
fait il lâche et en fait il revient et
il croit qu'il joue dans FC
[Musique]
comment tu vas la dame lui a échappé des
mains quoi
oui oui c'est pour ça qu'il a fait ça ah
mince ah oui c'est vrai
certainement demain
il est plus 15 secondes
Magnus là il y a 15 15 parce qu'il a mis
du temps à abandonné après mais il avait
peut-être cinq secondes d'avance et un
pion de plus je pense que Magnus avait
gagné la partie là
la souris comme quoi vous voyez hein ça
c'est encore une fois les limites
Internet les limites d'Internet qui font
que ben tu vois dans mes petites qui
aurais jamais fait en live
et voilà
c'est vrai que 25 secondes vous voyez
regardez le temps le temps final 15 pour
Magnus 13 secondes on va s'arrêter ça
aurait été toute façon ça aurait été
moche et bravo deux joueurs ils nous ont
tenu en haleine et bravo bravo bravo
supplémentaire à Ikao Nakamura qui
élimine Magnus Carson et qui aura sa
revanche demain contre Fabiano
erwana Stéphane oui donc demain à partir
de 17h on aura on aura cette grosse
on a Maxime je pense à 16h mais en fait
il faut garder les il faut qu'on regarde
vraiment les trucs parce qu'ils vont
mettre les finir en même temps
mais normalement si tout va bien on
pense qu'on a à 16h la finale de la
deuxième division avec Maxime contre
qui devra le battre deux matchs
d'affilée et on aura ensuite Nakamura
qui va prendre sa revanche contre Flavie
Kawana donc là ça fait vraiment le le
match de revanche
dans la division 1 et la division 2 donc
voilà en tout cas demain
ah non oui mais là c'est vrai qu'en
l'occurrence il rejoue contre des
joueurs qui contre qui sont déjà joué
c'est pour ça
notre ami Maxime qui c'est bien fait un
contrôle
c'était un récital de la part après
évidemment de cette offre a fait un gros
match aussi mais Maxime en dedans et il
a battu peut-être petit coup de pouce de
la niche gueri qui pourrait pourrait le
remettre
qui pourrait remettre en selle notre ami
Maxime ouais
yes on remercie tout le monde merci en
tout cas d'avoir suivi le stream comme
d'hab c'est super merci à toi Laurent
pour et merci à toi Stéphane pour
m'accompagner toujours un plaisir et
puis à bientôt à tous à demain et passez
une excellente soirée